INFORMATIONAL HEARING FOR
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
STREAMLINING SERVICES FOR
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE YELLOW HEART COMMITTEE. WE
ARE REQUIRING THAT MASK BE
WARRANTED FISCAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR PANEL
TESTIMONY TODAY WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN PROPER
SPACING. SO WE WILL ALSO BE-
ALLOWING REMOTE VIDEO
PARTICIPATION THROUGH WEBEX IN
ADVANCE OF THE HEARING EACH
PANELIST HAS BEEN PROVIDED
NECESSARY CONNECTIVITY
INSTRUCTIONS. IN ADDITION WE
WILL BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY PANELISTS CAN TESTIFY THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL
AS ON YOUR TV OR MONITOR
SCREEN. PLEASE NOTE THAT.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE TIME MAY
BE LIMITED FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD TO ENSURE THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS ADEQUATE TIME
TO HEAR FROM ALL MEMBERS. OF
THE PUBLIC. THE PURPOSE OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE IS TO EXAMINE
THE CURRENT HURDLES THAT
SURVIVORS OF INTERPERSONAL OR
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE FACE
WHEN SEEKING HELP FROM SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BY REVIEWING HOW SURVIVORS OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE ARE
SERVED I BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN GAME IMPORTANT
INSIGHT INTO THE WAYS IN WHICH
THE STATE'S CURRENT LAWS ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED OR ASCERTAIN
WHETHER CHANGES ARE NECESSARY.
TO ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS
RECEIVE THE BEST CARE AND
SUPPORT POSSIBLE THE FOCUS OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO EXAMINE
INTERPERSONALVIOLENCE DURING
THE CALL WITH NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WALL ST HOME ORDERS
HAVE SLOWED THE SPREAD OF
COVERT NINETEEN THEY HAVE
INADVERTENTLY AND UNFORTUNATELY
CREATED IDEAL CONDITIONS FOR
INTER PERSONAL OR INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE TO INCREASE.
AND AS THE PANDEMIC HAS
CONTINUED ON SO TOO HAS THE
ABUSE. THE PANDEMIC CREATED
SOCIAL AND LIVELIHOOD STRESSES
SUCH AS INCOME LOSS HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND FOOD AND
SECURITY WHICH HAS EXASPERATED
THE SILENT EPIDEMIC OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE. THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE. HEARING WILL
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE CRISIS
AMID THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IT WILL ASSESS
AVAILABLE RESOURCES AND CURRENT
OBSTACLES FOR SUPPORT AND
LASTLY DISCUSS STRATEGIES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR LET FOR THE
LEGISLATURE OUR GOAL IS TO
SHINE A SPOTLIGHT ON THE
PERSISTENT AND GROWING CRISIS
OF INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA HEAR FROM SURVIVORS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND POLICY
ADVOCATES AND WERE AND WHAT THE
STATE CAN DO TO IMPROVE THE
WAYS THAT WE SUPPORT VICTIMS.
AND SURVIVORS I BELIEVE THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND WHAT
ISSUES EXIST IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO IMPROVE AND
MOVE THE NEEDLE FORWARD TO
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT AND UPLIFT
SURVIVORS THAT ARE IN OUR
STATE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING TODAY'S TESTIMONY AND
BEING FURTHER EDUCATED ON THE
INTERPERSONAL PROVIDED CRISIS
AND WORKING WITH YOU ALL AS YOU
CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT WORK YOU
DO EVERY DAY ON FIGHTING THIS
CRIME AND WORKING TO PROTECT
SURVIVORS. AND I DO KNOW THAT
WE WILL BE HAVING- ONE OF MY
FELLOW SELECT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOINING US A LITTLE BIT LATER-
WHEN- WHEN HE ARRIVES I WILL
CALL ON HIM TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS- SO RIGHT NOW I WOULD
LIKE TO. INTRODUCE OUR FIRST
PANEL IF THOSE THAT ARE IN
PERSON WOULD COME ON UP TO THE
DíAS. AND THE PANEL CONSIST OF
CHAIRMAN AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FEDERAL NAY-
NAVA THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION. THE AUDIBLE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY OFFICE OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AND
MICHAEL READING SPECIAL
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. THIS PANEL OF
INCREDIBLY QUALIFIED IN THAT IN
THIS AREA AND HAVE SO MUCH YOU
COULD SAY I JUST HAVE THE
HIGHEST REGARD AND RESPECT. FOR
EACH OF YOU- THERE'S NO DOUBT
YOU COULD- FILL US WITH
INFORMATION. FOR THE NEXT HOUR
JUST FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE-
HOWEVER WE ARE LIMITED ON TIME-
SO I THINK THIS THE IMPORTANT
THING IS. IS TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
WHAT YOU DO HAVE TO SAY AND TO
KNOW THAT YOU ARE RESOURCE THAT
WE CAN CALL UPON. AND FOLLOW
UP- TO GET ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION SO THE PANEL WILL
GIVE US AN OVERVIEW OF THE
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE CRISIS
AMID THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THAT BEFORE- BEFORE
CHAIRMAN NAVA STARTS I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM COOPER AND OPEN IT
UP FOR- MISTER COOPER TO MAKE.
OPENING COMMENTS THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN I PLEDGE FOR BEING-
YOU KNOW A GOING ON OBVIOUS
WITH COBRE- YOU THINK ABOUT
LAST YEAR AND A HALF-
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE HAS
SKYROCKETED DRAMATICALLY YOU
SEEN OUR CHILDREN ABUSED. AND
WHAT'S FRUSTRATING FOR MYSELF
MISTER GRAYSON AS A LOT AS
LEGISLATORS- IS THE BILLS THAT.
CONTINUE CUTS THIS LEGISLATURE
AND WE NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
VICTIMS IT'S INTERESTING THAT
THE STATE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND- PAYS MONEY OUT TO
VICTIMS. 25% GO TO WOMEN AND
CHILDREN ABOUT THIRTEEN MILLION
A YEAR FOR THAT MONEY. AND NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GIVEN SOME
THAT VICTIMS COMPENSATION MONEY
TO OTHER FOLKS THAT- YOU KNOW
MY OPINION OR JUST- DON'T
DESERVE IT. AND YOU KNOW IT'S
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW A
DOMESTIC BUT IT'S NOT
CONSIDERED A VIOLENT CRIME. IN
THE PENAL CODE RIGHT NOW
TODAY'S WE SPEAK SO. IF YOU
BEAT YOURSELF UP YOUR
SIGNIFICANT OTHER- YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE BUT
I THINK WHEN YOU IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE ABUSIVE. TO YOUR SPOUSE
WE'RE TALKING WITH A FELONY ON
THAT. THEY MAYBE SHOULD DO A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE DONE WITH
THAT AND THAT THAT'S A REALLY
BIG ISSUE WHAT WE'RE SAYING
WE'RE SEEING VICTIMS GROUPS-
THAT ARE AFRAID TO COME FORWARD
AND TALK ABOUT SOME THESE
ISSUES. BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID
OF FUNDING BEING CUT. AND I
SEEN THAT DURING THE PAST YEAR.
SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED NEED TO BE TALKED
ABOUT IT GOES ON A REGULAR
BASIS I SPENT THIRTY YEARS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND I'M WHEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WASN'T
TREATED. AS A CRIME AND WHEN
THE CHANGES CAME ABOUT. AND I'M
RESPONDING TO A CALL AT THE
HOSPITAL THIS ONLY BEEN BEATEN
WITH JUMPER CABLES BY HER
HUSBAND. IN EVERY PORTION OF
HER BODY WAS BLACK AND BLUE
NUMBER THE EVIDENCE TECHNICIAN
TAKING PHOTOGRAPHS IN THE
HOSPITAL TO DOCUMENT THAT. BUT
WE SEE CASES TIME AND TIME
AGAIN- IT IT'S FRUSTRATING-
HELICOPTERS IN THIS BUILDING
THAT SUPPORTS TO- ADDRESS WOMEN.
AND CHILDREN'S ISSUES. AND YET
ON THE ISSUE OF DOMESTIC- FULL
TO SIGN ON IT- WITH THAT WAS
PULLED THE YEAR THE BILL FOR
BILL MONEY TO. IN UNDER- YOU'RE
OF A SUSPECT. THE PERPETRATOR
MYSTIC VIOLENCE YOUR PRICE HIS.
IF IT INVOLVED MYSTIC VIOLENCE
CANNOT CONSIDERED FOR YOUR
RELEASE. SO IF YOU'RE ABUSER
AND YOU HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF
ABUSE- DATA GOING THAT JUST
DECISION WHETHER YOU SHOULD GET
OUT- ON A LOWER BILL ARE R. O.
R. BUT IT'S NOT- SO IT'S THIS
IS TIMELY IS GOING ON OUR
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN ABUSED- THE
CHAIR CAME TO BE THE- AND I
KEPT THE INTERNET CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN- ABUSE OF
CHILDREN OF HAS GONE UP AS-
WELL AS CHILD **** AND THAT.
THE CHAIRMAN CAME OUT THERE AND
WITH THE END OF THE CAPITOL AND
TALKED ABOUT SOME THE
INVESTIGATOR STATEWIDE SO- LIKE
I SAID WE SEEN SO MANY WOMEN
THAT HAVE BEEN ABUSED THIS PAST
YEAR AND A HALF OF COVERT. AND
A LOT OF THEM CAREFULLY THEY
CAN GOING TO THEY HAVE NOWHERE
TO TURN TO THERE'S SOME GREAT
GROUPS OUT THERE BUT NO IT'S
TOUGH TO BREAK AWAY FROM YOUR
VIEWS OR ITS IT'S HARD. AND
SOMETHING GOOD BEGUN SLUG LOOK
FORTY HEARING TESTIMONY FROM
VICTIMS IN THE PANEL TO HEAR
HOW WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB BUT-
PART OF THIS IS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
IF IT IS IT IS REAL AND IT IS
IT'S LIKE SINCE. IT'S
FRUSTRATING BUT IT'S FUNNY WHAT
NOT FORTIES AND WANTED TO TELL
SOMEONE THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IS NOT CONSIDERED A VIOLENT
FELONY THERE LIKE IT'S DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS VIOLENCE IN THE
NAME. IN EVERY PERSON YOU TALK
TO. BUT WE IT SHOULD BE. S. OF
IRAQ. IF YOU INFLICT GREAT BALL
INJURY BUT IS NOT AN WHICH TO
REPEAL TO GET THAT CHANGED THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WE CAN'T A
CHANGE. SO ITS FIRST HOPEFULLY
TO FRUSTRATION VOICE- WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT YOU AND YOUR
SUPPORT YOU AND OTHER FOR THE
HEARING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SOME REMEMBER COOPER AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. WE ARE
HONORED TO HAVE YOU- WITH YOUR
EXPERTISE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE SUPPORT THAT YOU
PROVIDE. WITH THAT I WILL NOW
TURN BACK TO OUR PANELISTS AND
SHERMAN NOT IF YOU WOULD BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PEDRO NAVA AND THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION IS AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. IN THE PAST YEAR WE
ISSUED TWO REPORTS EXAMINING
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. THE
SERVICE COULD USE CAN TAKE MANY
FORMS PHYSICAL SEXUAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL OR FINANCIAL. IT
AFFECTS CALIFORNIANS OF ALL-BACKGROUNDS AGES AND GENDER
IDENTITIES TRAGICALLY. THE
PANDEMIC HAS CAUSED ALREADY
DISTRESSING RATES OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE DECLINED EVEN
HIGHER. IN OUR MAY TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE GETTING THE MONEY TO
THE OILS ON THE FRONT LINE WE
FOUND THAT RATES OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE INCREASED
DURING TIMES OF STRESS.
PARTICULARLY ECONOMIC STRESS
AND WHEN FAMILIES GATHERED
TOGETHER GOLD IN NINETEEN
SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES
COMBINED BOTH. AFTER GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ISSUED A STATEWIDE
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER IN MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND SHELTER STAFF
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. REPORTED
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE COMPARED
TO MARKEDLY NINETEEN. ONE
CRISIS SHELTER IN SACRAMENTO
REPORTED A 17% INCREASE IN
CALLS WHILE ONE IN LOS ANGELES.
AND A 20% INCREASE. THE FRESNO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
REPORTED FILING 77% MORE
DOMESTIC RELATED REPORTS IN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY.
COMPARED TO THE SAME TIME IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE IMPACT OF
THIS VIOLENCE OFTEN FALL
HARDEST ON THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG US MANY OF WHOM ARE
BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. OUR
REPORT FOUND THAT FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING ECONOMIC STRESS
ARE PARTICULARLY LIKELY TO BE
AFFECTED BY THIS ABUSE AND
THERE IS A CORRELATION BETWEEN
MALE UNEMPLOYMENT AND RATES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. BOTH WOMEN
AND MEN WHO ARE AMERICAN INDIAN
BLACK OR MULTIRACIAL REPORT
HIGHER RATES OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE THAN THEIR
PEERS OF OTHER RACES. WOMEN WHO
LIVE IN SMALL RURAL TOWNS ARE
SIMILARLY VULNERABLE TO
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. AND
ARE ALSO MORE LIKELY TO SUFFER
EXTENSIVE PROPERTY DAMAGE AND
BE MURDERED BY THEIR PARTNER
THAN WOMEN IN OTHER GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATIONS. SADLY THE CALL WITH
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR MANY VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF THIS ABHORRENT
ABUSE TO ACCESS LIFE SAVING
RESOURCES. THE FEAR OF CATCHING
CALL THE NINETEEN HAS PREVENTED
SOME VICTIMS FROM SEEKING
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE
HOSPITAL. AND WHILE MANY HEALTH
PROVIDERS IN TURN TO TELL
HEALTH AS A WAY TO PROVIDE
SOCIALLY DISTANCE CARE TO THEIR
PATIENTS THOSE LIVING IN
ABUSIVE HOUSEHOLDS CAN STRUGGLE
TO FIND THE PRIVACY NECESSARY.
TO SPEAK WITH THEIR DOCTORS OR
THERAPISTS. ACCESSING HELP IS
DIFFICULT WHEN ABUSERS ALSO
ISOLATE THEIR PARTNERS FROM
SOCIAL SUPPORT NETWORKS ABUSERS
USE NUMEROUS TACTIC TO PREVENT
OUR PARTNER FROM REACHING THE
OUTSIDE WORLD AND THE RESOURCES
THAT WILL HELP THEM. ESCAPE
DURING OUR STUDY ON INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE THE COMMISSION
HEARD STORIES OF SURVIVORS
WHOSE ABUSERS PREVENTED THEM
FROM LEAVING THE HOUSE TO GO TO
WORK OR TO SCHOOL. PLACES WHERE
THEY COULD RECEIVE HELP FROM
FROM THEIR FRIENDS OR CO
WORKERS OR TEACHERS. WE HEARD
OF ABUSERS TO TAKE COMPLETE
CONTROL OVER THE FAMILY
RESOURCES. METICULOUSLY
TRACKING THE VICTIM'S USE OF
MONEY AND PREVENTING THEM FROM
ACCESSING FUNDS IN A SHARED
BANK ACCOUNT. THIS BEHAVIOR IS
COMMON AMONG ABUSERS ONE STUDY
ON SURVIVOR FINANCIAL
INSECURITY FOUND THAT 1100% OF
SURVIVORS IN THE SAMPLE
EXPERIENCE SOME FORM OF
ECONOMIC ABUSE DURING THE
RELATIONSHIP. WHEN SURVIVORS
ARE ABLE TO ESCAPE THEIR
ABUSERS OFTEN WITH NO MONEY AND
NO WAY TO MAKE AN INCOME FOR
THEMSELVES. THEY STRUGGLE. TO
SURVIVE ON THEIR OWN. SOME GO
BACK TO ABUSER BECAUSE THEY
AFFORD TO STAY AWAY. NOW MORE
THAN EVER IT'S CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED NOT ONLY TO
ESCAPE THEIR ABUSER BUT TO
ESTABLISH A LIFE ON THEIR OWN.
IN OUR JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE REPORT BEYOND THE CRISIS A
LONG TERM APPROACH TO REDUCE
PREVENT AND RECOVER FROM THE
PARTNER VIOLENCE THE COMMISSION
PROVIDES A ROAD. FOR MORE
EFFECTIVELY PREVENTING THIS
APPEARS HELPING SURVIVORS AND
REHABILITATING PERPETRATORS.
FIRST CALIFORNIA MUST ADOPT A
STATE WIDE STRATEGY FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND APPOINT A
LEADER WILL BE ACCOUNTABLE. FOR
SUN STRATEGY WE NEED TO MAKE
HELP AVAILABLE BE FOR VICTIMS
ARE IN SIX SECONDS THE STATE
MUST AND FUND PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
ANTI VIOLENCE INITIATIVES SUCH
AS- BATTERER INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS MUST BE MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND DIVERSE SO THAT
THE STATE CAN HELP MORE PEOPLE.
THIRD CALIFORNIA MUST INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT. OF THIS EXISTING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RELATED
FIREARM LOS TO IMMEDIATELY
REMOVE WEAPONS FROM PEOPLE.
FROM OWNING THEM. THE STATE CAN
BETTER ENFORCE THESE LAWS BY
MODERNIZING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FIREARMS
DATABASES. AND REWORKING THE
SPECIAL AGENT CLASSIFICATION TO
BE MORE COMPETITIVE AND FINALLY
THE STATE MUST EXPAND PROMOTE
AND DEDICATE FUNDING. THE
RESOURCES THAT HELP SURVIVORS
ESTABLISH FINANCIAL
INDEPENDENCE SECURE HOUSING AND.
GAIN VALUABLE JOB EXPERIENCE.
SUCH RISKS LOOKING INCLUDE
CONNECTING SURVIVE WITH
APPRENTICESHIP. THEY CAN EARN A
LIVING THEY CAN THEIR EDUCATION.
CREATE STABLE SUSTAINABLE TO
EXPAND DOMESTIC. HOUSING FIRST
PROGRAM IN HELPING THE HELPERS
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO ASSIST
SURVIVORS OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE BY REQUIRING ITS STATE
GRANTS PROVIDE A LIVING WAGE
AND COST OF LIVING INCREASES
AWARDEES WE MUST PROVIDE FOR.
THOSE SERVICE PROVIDERS TODAY
CONTINUE THEIR CRUCIAL WORK.
GREATER ACTION MUST BE TAKEN TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA RESPONDS.
RIGOROUSLY AND EFFECTIVELY TO
THE HORRIFIC ABUSE THAT IS
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE THE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL HELP THE STATE CREATE A
COORDINATED COHESIVE STRATEGY
TO PREVENT DISOBEDIENCE AND
SUPPORT SURVIVORS WITH THEIR
LONG TERM NEEDS YEAH IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE A PART OF THIS
PANEL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING. COMMENTS QUESTIONS AND
RESPONSES FROM THOSE ARE PART
OF THE SCHOOLS WELL THANK. AND
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR THAT
GREAT TESTIMONY AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE HONORABLE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY.
SANDUSKY'S MICROPHONES YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON AND COOPER FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING I REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND I JUST
WANT TO TAKE ONE MOMENT THANK-
MISTER NAVA FOR THE ALL THE
WORK THAT THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION IS DOING I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM ON THE LABOR
TRAFFICKING ISSUES AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE THAT TYPE OF THINK TANK
REALLY HELP GUIDE US. I'M ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT- TIE WANNA
TALK ABOUT INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE AT THE TIME OF CODED.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS
BEEN BROUGHT TO LIGHT IS VERY
VERY HIDDEN PERVASIVE
EXPLOITATION OF INDIVIDUALS. ON
SO MANY LEVELS. THE VERY TOOLS
THAT WE USED TO KEEP PEOPLE
COBIT FREE HAVE NOW IMPACTED
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE IN THE MOST
DEVASTATING WAY. COVETOUS CAUSE
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF STRESS
ON FAMILIES. WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
THAT SOMEONE WHO MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE BE AN ABUSER HAS
BECOME AN ABUSER GIVEN THE
STRESSORS THAT EXISTS IN OUR
SOCIETY. UNEMPLOYMENT OF LACK
OF RESOURCES BEING CONFINED IN
THE HOME. AND I AND SO THERE
ARE FAMILIES THAT WERE REALLY
ILL EQUIPPED. A BECAUSE THERE
HAS NOT BEEN A HISTORY OF
VIOLENCE. WE ALSO SEE THAT-
THAT WITH THE SHELTER IN PLACE
THAT FOR THOSE THAT HAVE A
VIOLENT TENDENCY OR HAVE BEEN
VIOLENT PAST. HAVE ONLY
ESCALATED AND NOT ONLY AGAINST
THE ADULT VICTIM THEIR PARTNER
BUT ALSO AGAINST CHILDREN. AND
ONE OF THE STATE ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE NOTICED IS
THAT WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER. REFERENCE IN THAT IS
THAT AN ABUSER GETS ARRESTED
THEY'RE BROUGHT TO JAIL THEY'RE
BOOKED AND THEN THEY'RE
RELEASED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
UNDER THE EMERGENCY BELL
SCHEDULE WITHOUT EVEN TIME FOR
THE VICTIM TO FIND. TO TRY TO
SEEK RESOURCES TO GET AWAY FROM
THAT TO MOVE AWAY FROM THAT
HOUSE. BUT MANY OF THE WE ALSO
FOUND DO TO COPE IS THAT
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE. HAD NO ACCESS TO
HOSPITALS THEY COULD GO TO THE
HOSPITAL BUT THERE WAS NO THERE
WERE NO ADVOCATE RESOURCES
THERE. BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
ALLOWING OTHER PEOPLE INTO THE
HOSPITAL. AND FOR MANY THE
HOSPITAL WAS NOT EVEN A SAFE
PLACE BECAUSE HOSPITALS ARE
DEALING WITH COBIT. AND SO
GOING TO THE HOSPITAL AND
HAVING AT LEAST A MANDATORY
REPORT. MADE TO THE POLICE SO
THERE COULD BE SOME FOLLOW UP.
A LOT OF THAT WAS DROPPING OFF
THE WAYSIDE BECAUSE OF THE-
CONDITIONS THAT CODE HAD. MANY
OF THE SERVICES AS YOU
MENTIONED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON BECAME REMOTE OUR
MEDICAL SERVICES BECAME REMOTE.
WHICH IS. CAN BE EFFECTIVE
AFTER BUT NOT FOR THE
IMMEDIATE. INTERVENTION
SHELTERS ALSO HAD TREMENDOUS-
CHALLENGES THIS YEAR BECAUSE IF
A SHELTER HAD A POSITIVE COBIT
TEST THEY HAD TO CLEAR OUT THE
SHELTERS SO I KNOW IN MY COUNTY
THEY PURCHASE HOTELS. AND WE'RE
READ THE OUR SHELTER PARTNERS
WERE USING HOTELS TO BE ABLE TO
HOUSE PEOPLE BUT IT WAS NOT
OPTIMAL FOR SURE- AND PEOPLE
WERE TO ME IN HOTEL ROOMS DON'T
HAVE IN MOTEL ROOMS DON'T HAVE
KITCHENS. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
WAY TO GET HEALTHY EATING IF OR
EVEN. BEING ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF KIDS I PERSONALLY SAW WOMEN
WHO WERE LIVING IN CARS WITH
THEIR CHILDREN WHO FLED THEIR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I KNOW HERE
WITH US TODAY AND THE AUDIENCE
IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MY
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER SABRINA
FERAL. AND THERE'S SO MANY
WOMEN THAT WE WERE ABLE TO HELP
OUT BECAUSE THEY WERE THEIR
ONLY OTHER OPTION IS TO LIVE IN
THE CAR THAT HAD TO BE AWAY
FROM THE VIOLENT ENVIRONMENT.
BUT IN L. AS GOING ALONG WITH
THAT THERE'S IT AS IT WAS
POINTED OUT BY MR NOT AT THAT
THE LACK OF HOUSING. OF
AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR
EMERGENCY HOUSING POSE GREAT
CHALLENGES FOR US. ESPECIALLY
WHAT WE SEE WHICH IS. BEEN
EXACERBATED THROUGH COVERED IS
THAT PEOPLE THAT HAVE PETS.
WHAT I OFTENTIMES NOT LEAVE
UNLESS THEY COULD BRING THEIR
PET WITH THEM. BECAUSE THEY
KNEW THAT IF THEY LEFT THE PET
BACK THE PET WAS LIKELY TO BE
KILLED. OR ABUSED ITSELF.
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS AND
POPULATIONS HAVE BECOME VERY
MUCH MORE VULNERABLE- BECAUSE
AGAIN EVERYBODY WAS SHELTERED
IN HOME AND THEY WERE SHELTERED
IN HOME WITH WITH ABUSIVE
PEOPLE. SO THE A LOT OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES ALSO HAD
TO GO REMOTE I KNOW IT OUR
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER MANY OF
OUR PARTNERS WORK OFF SITE- WE
DID WHEN CO WITH FIRST HIT IS
THAT WE CLOSED DOWN FOR THREE
DAYS TO DO A DEEP CLEAN OF THE
AND- TIRE FACILITY- BUT  LOT
OF THOSE. A LOT OF THE SERVICES
ARE BEING DONE REMOTELY WHICH
IS NOT THE SAME ESPECIALLY IN
THAT CRITICAL TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT HOURS AFTER THE VICTIM
SURVIVORS COME FORWARD TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENED TO HER.
OR HIM IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT THERE WAS
PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT THERE WAS
THERE WERE NO OPTIONS AND SO
WHAT WE STARTED TO DO WAS TO
CREATE POSTERS WORK WITH THE
GROCERS ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALLOWED US TO
GIVE THEM POSTERS FOR EACH
COUNTY WITH RESOURCE NUMBERS
THEY WERE IN ALL THE GROCERY
STORE SO SOMEBODY EITHER A
PERSON WHO IS BEING ABUSED OR
SOMEONE WHO KNEW A PERSON BEING
ABUSE COULD NO HELP WAS OUT
THERE BECAUSE THERE WAS A GREAT
LACK OF COMMUNICATION DURING
COVERT EVERYTHING WAS ABOUT
COBIT. AND EVERYTHING WAS ABOUT
STAY HOME AND WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S THERE WAS
HELP AVAILABLE TO THEM. THE- A
CENTURY PEOPLE BECAME PRISONERS
IN THEIR OWN HOME AND IT WAS
GREAT BIG CHALLENGES FOR THEM
BEING ABLE TO SEEK HELP. THE.
SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AS I
SAID IS THAT WE CREATED OUR
STRATEGY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE BEING NOT JUST STRATEGIC
BUT COMPREHENSIVE SO OUR FIRST
STRATEGY WAS THAT WE NEEDED TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW THERE WAS HELP
AND THAT THERE WAS A WAY TO GET
AWAY FROM THAT ENVIRONMENT THAT
VIOLENT ENVIRONMENT. WE TRIED
TO ENGAGE YOUTH ALSO WE WORKED
WITH COMCAST TO BECAME A GREAT
PARTNER FOR US TO PUT
COMMERCIALS AND PSAS ON WE
WORKED WITH A SOCIAL MEDIA WE
WORK WITH RADIO STATIONS WE
JUST GOT THE WORD OUT THAT HELP
WAS AVAILABLE. AND WHAT WE SAW
WAS THAT PEOPLE STARTED COMING
TO THE JUSTICE CENTER. NOW OF
COURSE WE ARE VERY CAREFUL ALSO
BECAUSE WE HAD STAFF ON SITE.
SO WE HAD BIG BIG BASKETS OF
MASKS AND HAND SANITIZER
EVERYWHERE. GLASS PUT UPPER
FOUNDED THE BARRIERS SO THAT WE
COULD ACTUALLY SEE PEOPLE
ADDITIONALLY AND THEN
EVENTUALLY WE COULD TRANSITION
THEM TO BEING HELPED REMOTELY.
OF THE COUNT THE KEY WAS TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW THAT THERE WAS HELP
SO. WE WORKED AT THE GROCERY
STORES WHAT WE REALIZED WAS
THAT WE HAD A LOT OF OUR OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE ALSO
SERVICING BEING SERVICED BY THE
FOOD BANK. SO WE TOOK THOSE BIG
POSTERS AND MADE HIM SMALL AND
WE PUT HIM IN EVERY SIX EVERY
SINGLE FOOD BANK BAG. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE REALLY
STARTED TO SEE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TAKING THE HAVING THE COURAGE
TO MAKE THE PHONE CALL. OR TO
COME AND SEE US- IT WAS ALSO
HAPPENING IN- IN FAMILIES THAT
WE STARTED SEEING AN INCREASE
BOTH IN THE INTENSITY OF THE
VIOLENCE MUCH MORE INTENSE
INJURY HOSPITALS ARE CALLING US
AT THE JUSTICE CENTER ASKING US
TO HAVE MORE IMMEDIATE HELP-
THAT WE SAW LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPORTING A STRONGER AND MORE
SEVERE INJURIES. AND WE SAW WE
REMINDED OURSELVES THAT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MEANS HAD THE ABILITY
TO LEAVE IF THEY COULD
PSYCHOLOGICALLY BUT THEY HAD
THE ABILITY TO GO TO A HOTEL OR
GO STAY WITH FAMILY OR FRIENDS-
WE WERE REALLY FOCUSING ON
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T HAVE THAT
OPTION. WE ALSO IN ADDITION TO
OUR PSAS AND ARE OUT REACHES WE
TALK TO CHILDREN. WE TALK TO
CHILDREN ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
AND HOW THEY COULD THAT TELL
SOMEONE IF SOMETHING WAS
SOMEBODY WAS HURTING HIM I KNOW
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAD BANNERS ON THE
SCREEN FOR THE KIDS THEY WERE
THEY WERE IN SCHOOL REMOTELY
SAYING. IF SOMEONE'S HURTING
YOU YOU CAN CALL SOMEONE YOU
CAN CALL THE NUMBER. THE AND
THEN WE WORK WITH TEACHERS WHO
ARE ONLINE WITH THE KIDS TO
THAT THEY COULD PAY ATTENTION
IF THEY WERE SAYING SOMETHING
THAT WAS OUT OF. OUT OF SORTS.
AS I SAID BECAUSE OF THE
SHELTER BECAUSE OF A CODE IN
THE SHELTERS THAT WE HAD TO DO
WE STARTED USING HOTEL ROOMS.
AND WE WERE VERY CLOSE TO
PURCHASING A NINETY ROOM HOTEL
THAT WOULD HAD SIX FLOORS THAT
WE WERE GOING TO CONVERT INTO.
A SAFE AND- HOW SAFE HOUSING
FOR WOMEN AND CHILDREN- BUT
THAT DIDN'T WORK OUT. BUT SO
FAR SINCE KOBE TO SAP HAS
STARTED IN THE LAST YEAR WE'VE-
HOUSED OVER SIX HUNDRED WOMEN.
BOTH THROUGH EMERGENCY HOUSING.
SOME HAVING TO GOING TO HOTEL
ROOMS WE'VE HAD TO PIVOT. TO
HAVE FOOD ON SITE TO GIVE THEM
FOOD THAT CAN BE COOKED IN A
MICROWAVE. BECAUSE AGAIN WE
ASSUME HERE YOU'RE SAFE IN THE
ROOM. BUT HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
EAT. AND HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
FEED YOUR CHILDREN. SO WE BUY%
FOOD AND OUR FOOD BANK TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE GOT
FOOD THAT'S EXCEPT THAT IT. IS
ACCEPTABLE FOR. DURING HOTEL
ROOMS. THE BUT WE ALSO HAD TO
WE ALSO HAVE A STRATEGY OF
MOVING PEOPLE AWAY FROM THEIR
HOME BASE. IN SO THEY'LL BE OUT
IN THE EAST PART OF OUR COUNTY
AS OPPOSED TO NORTH PART OF THE
COUNTY AND VICE VERSA. WE WORK
WITH PARTNERS THEN TO FIND
PERMANENT HOUSING AND WE'VE
BEEN A RELATIVELY SUCCESSFUL IN
FINDING MORE PERMANENT HOUSING.
BUT THE RESOURCES AREN'T THERE
FOR VICTIM SURVIVORS TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES. AND THAT'S A BIG
THAT IS A HUGE ISSUE IS I LIKE
WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION WAS
FROM THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION TO HAVE A- YOU KNOW
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FIRST
HOUSING. INITIATIVE SO THAT
PEOPLE AT LEAST HAVE A WAY TO
GET INTO. LIVING I KNOW THAT
THROUGH THE VICTIMS OF CRIME.
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO PAY A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF RENT FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S HAD TO BE.
EMERGENCY RELOCATED AND WE
UTILIZE ALL OF THOSE SERVICES
FOR VICTIMS- BUT THE KEY IS
MAKING SURE THAT VICTIMS KNOW
THAT THAT'S AVAILABLE. FOR US
AT THE END OF THE DAY. COBIT IS
GIVEN US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY GIVE MORE FOCUS TO
EMPOWERING VICTIMS. BECAUSE WE
CAN HELP THEM IN A RECENT BY
RESPONDING WE CAN HELP THEM
WITH INITIAL RESOURCES WE CAN
DO A LOT OF THAT. BUT OUR GOA
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
VICTIM SURVIVOR WALKS AWAY. OF
BEING ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
HERSELF AND HER CHILDREN. SO AT
THE JUSTICE CENTER WE HAVE A
FOOD HUB WE THOUGHT THAT WE'D
BE GIVING OUT FOOD AS FOOD AS
MEDICINE WHICH IS A GREAT
INITIATIVE OF KALAMAZOO COUNTY.
IT'S NOT JUST GO GET YOUR
MEDICINE FOR YOUR DIABETES AND
THEN GO TO YOUR FRESH
VEGETABLES SO THAT YOU CAN USE
FOOD AS MEDICINE AS WELL.
DIDN'T QUITE WORK OUT SO NOW WE
HAVE GIFT CARDS THAT WE GIVE
PEOPLE WHEN THEY COME FOR ANY
SESSION WE GIVE THEM GIFT CARDS
TO. TO A DIFFERENT PLACES
TARGET I HAVE TO SAY HAS BEEN
AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER TO US.
AND HELPING PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO US SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
THEM TO THE VICTIMS AND THE
CLIENTS OF SURVIVORS. WE HAVE
ONGOING HEALTH CLASSES NOW. WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW TO SHOP
ECONOMICALLY HOW TO. MAKE FOOD
WE HAVE COOKING CLASSES ONLINE.
WE HAVE WE PROVIDED WITH
SUPPLIES- WE ENGAGE WITH THE
TRADES WITH THE UNIONS WE NOW
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
WOMEN. WHO HAVE. BEEN ABLE TO
BECOME CODE WRITERS. BECAUSE OF
ONE OF OUR PARTNERSHIPS WE HAVE
WOMEN THAT ARE NOW CARPENTERS.
AND ELECTRICIANS ENTERING
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. AND
THESE ARE ALL WAYS THAT WE'RE
HELPING TO END THAT CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE. BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES
AND NOT BE DEPENDENT. ON A
PERSON WHO'S ABUSING THEM. WE
ALSO WERE ABLE TO THROUGH
GRANTS THAT WE RECEIVED WERE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CHROMEBOOKS FOR
THOSE. WHO ARE WORKING WITH US
AND OTHERS I MEAN FOR MANY OF
THE FAMILIES THEY DIDN'T HAVE
pCOMPUTERS. SO WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THOSE. A AND I WILL SAY
THAT- THANKFULLY BECAUSE WE'VE
GOTTEN ALL THE THESE GRANTS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO. DO MUCH
MOREIN TERMS OF PROVIDING
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES. WITH THE
CHILDREN WE DID CONTINUE OUR
CAMPO. AT BUT WE DID IN OUR
PARKING LOT. INSTEAD OF AWAY
CAMP ALTHOUGH THIS SUMMER WE
DID HAVE A WAY CAMPS. ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES AS THE
COURTS CLOSED. AND YOU THERE IT
WAS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO GET A
PROTECTIVE ORDER ESPECIALLY AN
EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE ORDER.
WHEN THE COURTS CLOSE DOWN.
THAT OR THEY WERE BECAME REMOTE
THERE WAS IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
TECHNOLOGY YOU COULD NOT. IF
YOU DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO DO IT
SO. THAT'S BEEN A HUGE PROBLEM
FOR US ALSO WITH TRYING TO
PROCESS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
THROUGH COURT. IS ACCUSED HUGE
ISSUE AND THE COURTS ARE NOW
STARTING TO OPEN BACK UP. BUT
OF COURSE A BIG BIG CHALLENGES
WITH CODED WHO CAN ACTUALLY
COME INTO A COURT ROOM. HOW CAN
THEY DO IT SO AT THE JUSTICE
CENTER WE'VE SET UP A SYSTEM.
WHERE THEY CAN COME THERE WE
CAN HELP THEM GET THEIR MERCY
ORDERS. AND THEN HELP THEM ONE
OF OUR PARTNERS HELPS IN IN THE
COURTROOM WE SEND OUR
NAVIGATORS TO BE WITH PEOPLE IN
COURT. OR AT LEAST ONLINE IN
COURT. WE WANT TO THE SURVIVORS
TO COME OUT OF THIS EXPERIENCE.
EMPOWERED AND STRONGER. AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
AREAS WHERE WE'VE JUST REALLY
BY WE REALLY HAVE GIVEN FOCUS
WHERE THERE'S NOT A LOT OF.
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER. THEY GET OUT OF BED THAT
EXPERIENCE. OUR PROGRAM IS
CALLED STEP UP. OF WHICH IS
ABOUT. FINANCIAL LITERACY AND
OTHER OTHER- AWARENESS
PROGRAMS. WE HAVE A PARTNERSHIP
WHERE WOMEN ARE LEARNING HOW
TO. TAKE CARE OF THEIR OWN
NEEDS TAKEN. CHANGE ELECTRICAL
OUTLETS THEY CAN FIX OUR OWN
CARS. IT'S QUITE AMAZING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. WE'VE GOT HOW TO
SHOP SMART. WE HAVE A WORKING
WITH DIG DEEP FARMS WHERE WOMEN
ARE LEARNING HOW TO GROW THEIR
OWN FOOD. AND ESPECIALLY WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGING THE CHILDREN WITH
HAVE HOMEWORK HELPER. IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR MANY OF THESE
YOUNG KIDS TO HAVE ACTUALLY
GOTTEN AN EDUCATION BY A
COMPUTER SCREEN. AND WE'RE SO
CONCERNED. THAT THESE CHILDREN
HAVE MISSED A YEAR. PLUS OF
EDUCATION. WHICH WE KNOW THAT.
THAT PUTS THEM ALREADY AT A
DISADVANTAGE AS THEY GROW INTO
ADULTHOOD. AND SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY THE LAST THING IS THAT-
WE ARE TRUMP RECOVERY CENTER AS
WELL. AND THAT WE HAVE A PHD IN
FIVE THERAPISTS WHO WORK AT THE
TRUMP RECOVERY CENTER. SOME OF
THOSE ARE BEING DONE REMOTELY
QUITE EFFECTIVELY WE'VE HAD
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE THAT
WE'VE SERVED IN THE LAST YEAR.
AT THE JUSTICE CENTER TEN
THOUSAND CLIENTS HAVE COME TO
THE IT JUST SINCE JANUARY WHICH
IS SUBSTANTIALLY MORE. THAN
WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS- IN DUE IN
LARGE PART DUE TO. BOTH THE
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE AS WELL AS
THE ON GOING SUPPORT THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING TO WOMEN AND CHILDREN
AND ANY AND MEN WE SERVE ABOUT
A THOUSAND MANY YEAR. WHO ARE
ON THEMSELVES VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- IF I COULD
JUST SAY ONE MORE THING AND
THAT IS THAT- I JUST. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE BUT WE'RE ALSO SEEING
A HUGE INCREASE IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VIOLENCE AGAINST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. AND
NO ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT'S BEEN
A VERY STRONG FOCUS OF YOURS.
WE HAD WE LOOKED AT ONLINE ADS.
FOR ONE TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD
IN MY COMMUNITY AND THERE WERE
ELEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE AD
SELLING WOMEN AND GIRLS FOR SEX.
WE WHAT WE COULD NARROW THAT
DOWN TO NINE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE SEPARATE WOMEN. AND OUR
ANALYTICS TOLD US THAT AT LEAST
70% WERE UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY. AND THERE'S SO MUCH
VIOLENCE ON THE STREET BOTH
FROM TRAFFICKERS WHO ARE TRYING
TO CONTROL THE VICTIM FROM
PURCHASERS WHO ARE. DOING THIS
AND IT'S SO FRIGHTENING THAT
THIS IS ALL STILL HAPPENING IN
THE TIME OF COBIT WHICH MAKES
ALL OF THESE INDIVIDUALS SO
INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE. AND THEN
WE SEEING MORE VIOLENCE BETWEEN
THE- THE TRAFFICKED
INDIVIDUALS. SO THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT WE'RE DOING NOW OUT ON THE
STREET AND TRYING TO PRY BRING
THESE RESOURCES TO TRAFFICKED
VICTIMS WE'RE TRYING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES. WE HAVE
A PARTNERSHIP OF TWENTY PARTNER
AGENCIES JUST TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE VIOLENCE OF TRAFFICKED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON THE
STREETS ARE ON THE INTERNET IN
AT LEAST ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
BEYOND- AND SO. YOU KNOW
ANYTHING WITH THAT WE CAN DO TO
FURTHER BOTH FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT OR FROM ANY OTHER
STANDPOINT- WE'RE WE'RE ALWAYS
STAND READY TO HELP. AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU DIEGO O'MALLEY FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR THE PASSION
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN. THE EFFORT
AND ENERGY YOU PUT INTO THIS
NOW WE WILL TURN TO MICHAEL
READY. SPECIAL ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL. GOOD MORNING
JERRY GRAYSON REMEMBER. ARE YOU
ON I THINK I I'M I'LL START A
GOOD MORNING GRACE GOOD MORNING
FAMILY COOPER HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL READING I AM S. IS WITH
THE CAL- GENERAL'S OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TO
SPEAK ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC. PRIOR TO JOINING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR
EIGHT YEARS I SPENT MANY OF
THOSE YEARS WORKING ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES AND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT IS VERY
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU TO DO MALLEY AND CHAIRMAN
NAVA I'M HONORED TO BE ON A
PANEL WITH A BOTH OF THEM AND I
BELIEVE VERY DEEPLY IN THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING REALLY ON
THE GROUND AND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE VICTIMS. LIKE THE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTED
HERE TODAY THE DEPARTMENT IS
COMMITTED TO DOING EVERYTHING
IN ITS POWER. TO PROTECT THE
VICTIMS OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
RECOGNIZES THAT. PROVIDE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC PRESENTED
SIGNIFICANT AND UNIQUE
CHALLENGES TO VICTIMS OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE.
LIKEWISE IT AFFECTED LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROSECUTORS THE
COURTS. OFTEN HAMPERING THEIR
ABILITY TO INVESTIGATE CASES.
AND MOVE THESE CASES QUICKLY
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. GIVEN THAT
THESE ARE ONGOING PROBLEMS THAT
VICTIMS CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
EVERY DAY. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS DEDICATED TO ENSURING THE
DEPARTMENT CAN HELP IN WHATEVER
CAPACITY POSSIBLE. THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE STATISTICS CENTER OR C.
J. S. C. COLLECTS AND REPORTS
STATISTICAL DATA TO ALLOW FOR
ASSESSMENT OF CRIME AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS DATA IS AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WEBSITE
OPEN JUSTICE IT'S A PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE. THE DOJ RESEARCH
CENTER OR DO J. R. C. IS THE
ANALYTICAL SIDE OF THE HOUSE D.
O. J. R. C. USES A SCIENTIFIC
APPROACH TO AMONG OTHER AREAS
PERFORM DATA ANALYSIS AIMING TO
EMPOWER THE DEPARTMENT AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT MORE GENERALLY TO
MAKE DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS.
CJSC AND D. O. J. R. C.
PROVIDED THE DATA THAT I HAVE
TO OFFER TODAY AND I DID
PROVIDE SOME SLIDES AND GET THE
FIRST ONE OBSERVER GET ASKED TO
MOVE TO THE SECOND SLIDE. THANK
YOU. SO THIS FIRST TABLE IS
BASED ON DATA COLLECTED BY CJSC
AND THE AUTOMATED CRIMINAL
HISTORY SYSTEM OR A C. H. S. IT
SHOWS THAT THE NUMBER OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RELATED
CALLS. ARRESTS AND CONVICTIONS
EACH YEAR FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DATA IS IN MOST
INSISTS STILL BEING COMPILED.
THE TOTAL CALLS- DATA WAS
ORIGINALLY RELEASED IN THE
CRIME IN CALIFORNIA PUBLICATION
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
RELEASED IN JULY. AND IT'S
WORTH NOTING OF COURSE THAT
THIS DATA. IS BASED ON
REPORTING FROM LOCAL ENTITIES
AND MAY VERY WELL BE INCOMPLETE.
AS YOU CAN SEE LOOKING ON THE
SLIDE THE TWENTY TWENTY SHE'S
ME IN TWENTY TWENTY WE SAW THE
BIGGEST YEAR TO YEAR DROP IN
CALLS ARRESTS AND CONVICTIONS
AS COMPARED WITH THE YEAR TWO
YEAR DATA OF THE PRECEDING FIVE
YEARS. IF WE COMPARE THE
AVERAGE OF THE FIVE YEARS
PRECEDING TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY ITSELF REPORTING
CALLS DECREASED BY TWO POINT
NINE PERCENT. REPORTED ARRESTS
DECREASED BY THIRTEEN POINT 6%
AND REPORTED CONVICTIONS
DECREASED BY THIRTY SEVEN POINT
TWO PERCENT. WHILE SOME OF THE
DRUG COULD BE EXPLAINED BY
FEWER ACTUAL ARRESTS AND
CONVICTIONS DELAYS IN REPORTING
DATA TO THE DEPARTMENT LIKELY
ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO THE REDUCED
NUMBERS. AND WE CAN MOVE TO
THAT SECOND SLIDE. THE SECOND
SLIDE WAS COMPILED BY DOJ RC
IT'S BASED ON THE DATA FROM A
C. H. S. PROVIDING ARREST DATA
WHICH IS REQUIRED TO BE
PROVIDED TO US AT THE TIME OF
ARREST MUHAMMAD IS ARRESTED AND
BOOKED ON A PARTICULAR CHARGE.
THE DATA IS SENT TO US THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE THE DATA THROUGH
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY ONE ON
HERE. AS YOU CAN SEE LOOKING AT
THE CHART THAT SHOWS AVAILABLE
DATA ON ARRESTS BY MONTH FROM
TWENTY TWENTY SHE'S ME FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN THROUGH AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. JUST LOOKING
AT JANUARY AND FEBRUARY ARRESTS
STATE ABOUT THE SAME BETWEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY PRE PANDEMIC THERE WERE
ABOUT 1-000-020-0210 THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED ARRESTS PER MONTH
EACH YEAR IN THE PRECEDING FIVE
YEARS AND ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THREE AND
TWENTY TWENTY RIGHT MIDDLE.
SAME WITH FEBRUARY THE NUMBER
OF ARRESTS AVERAGED IN THE HIGH
NINE THOUSANDS AND LOW TEN
THOUSANDS IN THE PRECEDING FIVE
YEARS AND FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY CAME IN RIGHT AT NINE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
NINE. HOWEVER STARTING IN MARCH
WE START TO SEE A NOTABLE DROP
THE FIRST FULL MONTH OF THE
PANDEMIC APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
SIDE DECREASE IN ARRESTS FROM
ABOUT TEN OR ELEVEN THOUSAND A
MONTH IN THE PREVIOUS FIVE
YEARS DOWN 280-004-0070 THAT
TREND CONTINUE THROUGHOUT THE
REST OF TWENTY TWENTY AND AS
YOU CAN SEE IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE NUMBER OF
ARRESTS PER MONTH AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS CLOSER TO THE
PANDEMIC MONTHS OF TWENTY
TWENTY. THAN ANY PRECEDING YEAR.
THIS IS OF COURSE AN EXTREMELY
LIMITED SNAPSHOT AND AS I SAID
BEFORE IT'S BASED ON IN MANY
INSTANCES DATA THAT'S REPORTED
FROM FROM LOCAL AGENCIES. THIS
IS THAT SAID THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE. THE DATA OF COURSE DOES
NOT AND CANNOT TELL THE FULL
STORY IT DOES NOT TELL THE
STORIES OF INDIVIDUAL VICTIMS
THESE VICTIMS ARE NOT NUMBERS
AND THEIR LIVED EXPERIENCES
CANNOT BE REPRESENTED NEARLY
THREE CHARTS. LIKEWISE IT DOES
NOT TELL THE FULL STORY THE
PANDEMIC WE KNOW FROM STUDIES
STORIES HAVING BEEN THERE AND
FROM THE TESTIMONY THAT WILL
HEAR AND HAVE HEARD TODAY. THAT
CLOSED COURTS DELAYED REPORTING
TO DOJ AND CHANGES IN THE LOCAL
DATA SYSTEMS MAY ACCOUNT FOR
THE CLIENT TO SEE AND THE
TWENTY TWENTY DATA. TO EXPLAIN
THIS DATA WE NEED TO HELP THE
VICTIMS ADVOCATES LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S AND EXPERTS IN
THE FIELD. FORTUNATELY THIS
ROMAN THIS PANEL HAS PLENTY OF
THOSE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THEM AND HOPE THAT
TOGETHER WE CAN WORK TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THIS
INFORMATION WITH YOU ON BEHALF
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU OUR PARTNERS
TO FACE THESE CHALLENGES HEAD
ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
REDDING AND I- WANT TO DEFER TO
MY- COMMITTEE MEMBER IF HE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS AND I ALSO HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANNA
THINK THE MAIL YOU FOR ALL YOU
DO I HAVE THE PASSION YOUR
VOICE AND ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE. IN SUPPORT OF WOMEN AND
CHILDREN IS IT'S FANTASTIC AND
JUST KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK- IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY LAST YEAR. WE
HAD ME PULLS UP REAL QUICK.
WITH TWELVE THOUSAND PLUS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
REPORTED DURING COVERT. NUMBER
TEN- DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOMICIDES. THAT'S A LOT- THE
BIG PART REFER THE VICTIMS BUT
THIS BETTER INTERVENTION AND
ONE THING WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW. IS WITH COVERT- FOLKS GET
RELEASED- THE ABUSERS. AND THEY
HAVE PROGRAMS THAT OBVIOUSLY
WITH YOUR INCARCERATED YOU'RE
GOING TO MAYBE ALCOHOLISM OR
SUBSTANCE ABSE PROGRAMS. AND
ALSO ANGER MANAGEMENT THEN ONCE
THEY GO OUTSDE- IF THEY DON'T
CONTINUE THE COURSES- NOTHING
HAPPENS AND THAT'S. REALLY A
BIG ISSUE IS TRYING TO GET THEM.
DOES A LOT OF THESE FOLKS
BILLION TO BE THERE LIVE. AND
GET THEM BACK ON. THE RIGHT
TRACK. YES WE'VE BEEN BECAUSE
END OF PAROLE. SPECIFIC PAROLE.
IF YOU DON'T ATTEND YOUR
PROGRAMS. YOU'RE NOT THERE'S
NOTHING NOTHING HAPPENS TO YOU.
ALSO SELECT OUT THERE SO
SOMEHOW WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT-
TO CHANGE YOUR BEHAVIOR WITH
THAT. BUT YOU FOLKS THAT HAVE
MISTER PROGRAMS IN THE NUMBER
OF VIOLENT I'M- MISSING THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE IN. THE FACILITY
YOU HAVE MORE CONTROL OVER
OVER. THE OLD DAYS IT WAS
FLASHING CARCERI SOMEONE FOR
THIRTY DAYS. TO GET BACK ON
THAT TRACK SO I'M NOT REALLY
SURE MAYBE. DEAL MILITANTS THAT
DOT SUGGESTION. TO HOW WE HOW
WE DEAL WITH THAT. WELL I KNOW
THAT. FOR SOME OF THE COUNTY SO
WE'RE NOT UNDER THE CHIEF
JUSTICE'S EMERGENCY ORDER
ANYMORE. BUT FOR SOME OF THE
COUNTIES THEY ARE. AS SOMEBODY
WHO VIOLATES THEY CAN COME BE
BROUGHT BACK IN AND THEY'LL PUT
A BELL ON THEM. SO THAT THEY
ACTUALLY CAN MEET NEED TO STAY
AND I THINK THAT YOUR POINT IS
THAT THERE HAS TO BE A
CONSEQUENCE FOR THE ACTION. AND
IF THERE'S NO CONSEQUENCE IN
THERE'S NO DETERRENT TO. STOP
ENGAGING IN THE CONDUCT. SO
HAVING THE FLASHING CORPORATION
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE OTHER
THING THAT I'VE SEEN IS THAT WE
IT IS MANDATED IN CALIFORNIA
THAT AND- SOMEONE WHO'S
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
MUST PARTICIPATE IN A FIFTY TWO
WEEK DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAM.
BUT THAT IS- THERE'S ALL THAT
REALLY ENFORCED. AND TO THE
SAME TO THE SAME POINT THAT. IF
SOMEBODY IS ORDER TO GO TO A
TREATMENT PROGRAM. THAT AND
THEY JUST DON'T SHOW UP. OR IN
MY COUNTY WE HAD ONE WHERE THEY
WERE JUST GOING AND PAYING A
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND LEAVING.
OUT WE HAVE TO HAVE I BELIEVE
MORE TEETH. TO THAT SO THE
COURT WILL ACTUALLY TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY WHEN THEY IT'S
REPORTED BACK TO THEM THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL. IS NOT ATTENDING
THE PROGRAM- THERE IS A LOT OF
RESEARCH AROUND THE PROGRAM'S A
FIFTY TWO WEEK PROGRAM IS. SET
WITH THE STANDARD CURRICULUM.
AND THERE'S SOME MOVEMENT THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD BE IDENTIFIED
MORE DID MORE DIRECTLY ABOUT
WHAT THEIR ISSUES ARE BECAUSE
NOT EVERYBODY IS. BEING DRIVEN
BY THE SAME BEHAVIOR OR THE
SAME- ISSUES AND- I DO SUPPORT
THAT I KNOW WITH OUR SEX
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT BOARD. THAT
YOU'RE LEGISLATURE PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT WE PUT A
SPONSORED. TO INDIVIDUALIZE THE
TREATMENT TO HAVE PEOPLE
ASSESSED. AND THAT REALLY IS
ABOUT A RISK ASSESSMENT AND I
THINK IF WE LOOK AT. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN THE SAME WAY THAT
WE LOOK AT OTHER CRIMES OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE. LOOKING
AT RISK IS REALLY THE KEY. AND
IF WE CAN REDUCE THE RISK OF RE
OFFENDING THEN. WE HAVE THE
ENGAGEMENT HAS BEEN WORTH IT.
UP BUT I AND THAT'S ONE AREA
WHERE I THINK WE SHOULD WE
COULD EXPLORE MORE. WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FIRST TO
MATCH IT STILL LOOK AT THIS
FAMILY MATTER. AND WE WILL HAVE
TO TAKE IT OUT OF THAT REALM
AND RECOGNIZES THE VIOLENT
CRIME THAT IT IS. THANK YOU THE
EVER MISTER READING ON YOU TALK
ABOUT THE REPORTS DOJ GETS THIS
EVERY CITY REPORT THEIR DATA
ARE ONLY CITIES OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND POPULATION I BELIEVE
THIS IS EVER AND IT SHOULD
COME FROM THE COUNTY'S I
BELIEVE BUT IT IT IT SHOULD NOT
BE- JUST THE COUNTIES ARE JUST
THE CITIES THAT ARE UNDER A
CERTAIN POPULATION IT IT'S
EVERYBODY COULD YOU ARE
SOMETIMES WITH WITH WITH FBI
UNIFORM CRIME REPORTING
WHATEVER THAT IS- THE ONLY GET
REPORTS OF CITIES OVER HER
THOUSANDS POPULATION. SO THAT
SKEWS NUMBERS FOR A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT ASSAULT AND THE THINGS
THAT WE SKEWS NUMBER SO I
DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT NO THAT'S
IT YOU BRING UP A VERY GOOD
POINT AND THE REALITY IS THAT-
ARE THE SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE FBI HAS IN PLACE TO TRACK
SOME OF THIS- WE TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW WASTE WASTE TO IMPROVE
IT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT AND LOOKING TO- MOVE
FORWARD ON THAT JUST AS A
MATTER OF A FACT. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WE DON'T HAVE INFORMATION
FROM WE HAVE SOME INFORMATION
FROM TWENTY TWENTY SEP FROM
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT MOST OF
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE IS FROM A
YEAR AGO AND MOST OF THE DATA
WE HAVE- AS I SAID IT IT MAY
WELL BE THAT THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION THAT HAS YET TO
COMMENT ALL OF WHICH IS TO SAY
AS WE'RE SITTING HERE HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE BEST DATA
ON HAND WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING.
TO I BELIEVE IS OFTEN. AT THE
PRESS TIME. WHEN TALKING ABOUT
WHAT MAYBE THE ASSAULTS WERE IN
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA WHAT FBI
DOES OR WHAT SOME OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE DONE. HAS
TAKEN A SAMPLING. OF SOME
LARGER CITIES WHAT THEY REPORT
OUT AND THEN TRIED TO
EXTRAPOLATE BASED ON THAT. I
DON'T HAVE ANY OPINION AN
APARTMENT CERTAINLY DOESN'T
HAVE ANY PAIN- ON THAT THE
POINT IS JUST THAT WE DON'T
HAVE COMPLETE DATA. AND WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE COMPLETE DATA
AND TELL SOME TIME. ACT AFTER
THE DATE IN QUESTION. THANK YOU
SO FIRST THE FOLKS THAT MAYBE
DIDN'T CATCH THAT SO THE FBI
REPORTS. INFORMATION USING
UNIFORM CRIME REPORTING. AND
THE ONLY DEAL WITH CITIES OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION.
WAS A LOT OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
THAT HAVE BELOW HUNDRED
THOUSAND POPULATION. JUST THINK
ABOUT ALL THE CITIES OF LESS
THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND. PEOPLE
CITIZENS. NOT CATCHING
INFORMATION. SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT STATS IN IN CRIME STATS.
IT'S KIND OF CUTE BECAUSE YOU
LIVING OUT A BIG. THAT CAN
pSTATISTICS THAT'S. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER AND- JUST REAL
QUICK I KNOW WE'RE WAY OVER
TIME FOR THE FIRST PANEL. BUT
I. I'M IT WOULD BE INTERESTING
TO FIND OUT- ESPECIALLY IN THE
PAST YEAR AND A HALF. HOW MUCH
OF THAT IS MY FACTOR NUMBERS
WERE STAGGERING. HOW MUCH OF
THE LACK OF REPORTING OR THE
LACK OF A REST OR OR
CONVICTIONS. OUR WHOLE FOOD
RELATED VERSES POLICY THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING AND PASSING
AT THE SAME TIME. AND IT JUST
SO HAPPENS TO BE BOTH COVERT
AND THIS POLICY HAPPENING. BUT
IF COVERT WASN'T IN EXISTENCE.
WITH THE POLICY THAT WE WE'VE
BEEN.PUSHING THROUGH IN
PASSING. WHAT KIND OF RESULTS
WOULD YOU HAVE SUSPECTED- SO
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE COULD
GET INFORMATION- FROM EACH OF
YOU ON WHAT YOU THINK WAS
STRICTLY COVERT RELATED AND
I'VE COVERED WASN'T HERE. THAT
WITH- DISPARITY WOULD NEVER
EXISTED VERSES- POLICY WISE AND
WHAT WE'RE FACING. AND HOW
WE'RE TRENDY- WITH POLICY I
THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY
INTERESTING TO HEAR FROM YOU
ALL ON THAT. AND WE CAN DO THAT
AT A LATER TIME- THANK YOU SO
VERY VERY MUCH TO CHAIRMAN-
NAVA TO DISTRICT. ATTORNEY
VALLEY AND TO MR READING- SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. IT WAS
INCREDIBLE- I WOULD LIKE TO NOW
INVITE OUR SECOND PANEL- TO THE
DYESS. OR REMOTELY JIM JUST
MORE QUESTIONS MR READING
JERSEYS. ON THE REPORTING
REPORT. IN MY ROOM RIGHT A
WRONG THE REPORTING NOT MEANT
IS. IT IS REPORT YEAH THAT IS
IT IS MANDATORY. AND AS FAR AS
I UNDERSTAND IT'S MANDATORY
THAT THE YES OKAY. THANKS IT'S
ACTUALLY MANDATORY GET LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS SEVERAL
OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS THE
HOSPITALS REQUIRED TO REPORT
THE- I MEAN THERE'S A WHOLE
LIST OF PEOPLE ARE MANDATED
REPORTER FOR. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCORRECT BUT DID DO THE STATS
ALWAYS GET THE LESS I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S ON FORSMAN
I THINK THAT THAT'S THE THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT MY HESITATION IS
THAT THERE IS- THERE'S LOTS OF
DATA. AND SO IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO SAY UNEQUIVOCALLY THE DATA
IS REQUIRED TO BE. REPORTED
THAT THERE IS SOME DATA THAT IS
REQUIRED TO BE REPORTED WHEN WE
GET INTO MORE SPECIFICS NOT
NECESSARILY- BUT AS A GENERAL
MATTER THE CITIZENS THAT I
PROVIDED TODAY. BOTH COME FROM
AUTOMATIC REPORTING SOMEONE
SOMEBODY'S BOOKED AND SO THE
ECHS DATA'S WHEN SOMEBODY'S
BOOKED AND- THAT PRETTY MUCH
AUTOMATICALLY COMES TO US. AND
THEN THE REMAINING- I HAVE. A
RECIPE CALLS AND CONVICTIONS
DATA IS REQUIRED TO BE
REPORTED. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE WILL NOW INVITE OUR
SECOND PANEL TO THE DYESS. OR
REMOTELY- AND- THIS PEN WILL BE
ON AFFECTED RESOURCES AND
CURRENT OBSTACLES FOR SUPPORT-
WITH THIS TODAY IS WATER HILL
SURVIVOR. KALINA FOWLER
SURVIVOR WILLIAM MUCH. EVER
NATALIE LEAVES CREATOR- CENTER
DIRECTOR FOR CENTRAL CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER ANGELA ROSES START
DIRECTOR PROJECT SISTER FAMILY
SERVICES IF THEY WILL COME
FORWARD- FOR THOSE THAT ARE
HERE IN PERSON WE HAVE TO OUT
OF THE FIVE AND THREE ON WEBEX-
THAT WILL BE JOINING US. PLEASE
COME UP AND- THEY'RE JUST STATE
AGAIN PANEL ONE. OF REALLY JUST
FANTASTIC INFORMATION AND
THINGS SO WE DEFINITELY NEEDED
HERE WE ARE- PRESSED FOR TIME
SO IF WE COULD KEEP OUR
TESTIMONY RIGHT TO THE LIMIT
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH WE WILL
BEGIN WITH. WALTER HILL A
SURVIVOR WHO HAS JOINED US. VIA
WEBEX. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
WATER HERE- I CURRENTLY RESIDE
IN CHICAGO I'M A COLLEGE
STUDENT I'M NOT EXTENDING MY
STATE UNIVERSITY I'M TAKING
CLASSES ONLINE. HERE AND I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON RESOURCES AND
WERE SUPPORT FIRST OF MARCH
HELLO. NUMBER NINETEEN HAS
IMPACTED THE RESOURCES TO
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS AND-
PERSONALLY FOR ME DOORS LOCKED
OUT OF CHICAGO MOBILITY. HAS
BEEN A STRUGGLE WITH CONTINUING
WITH RUSH AS FAR AS ANYTHING
OFF PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS TO COVER NINETEEN
AM WITHOUT HAVING TO RUSH FOR
SYSTEM. AND I WAS RECENTLY
INCARCERATED. IN MAY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN APRIL TWENTY TWELVE
AND THEN AGAIN IN TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH WAS WHEN WE BEGAN. PRETTY
MUCH WAS JUST A HASSLE ON HOW
DOES THIS IMPACT YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER BE CONSUMMATED DURING
THE ONE IS PANDEMIC. WE WERE
GETTING THE RIGHT TREATMENT- WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO SEE OUR
FAMILIES. EVERYTHING WAS JUST
PRETTY MUCH TOOK IT AWAY FROM
US IN. JUMP BACK TO THE SOCIETY
HAS BEEN THAT MANY OBSTACLES
FOR ME ARM. PRETTY MUCH OUR
RESOURCES HAS BEEN SCATTERED
AND IT'S BEEN HARD TO YOU KNOW
MOVE ONE MOLD FOR THE DOCTOR
THE RIGHT NOT TO REST
PERSISTENT AND CALL IN NINETEEN
HAS JUST BEEN A CHERRY ON THE
TOP BUT I'VE STILL BEEN. MOVING
FORWARD AND PUT MY BEST EFFORT
AND PUTTING MY BEST AFTER
SEEING. THE RESOURCES SUCH AS
HEALTHCARE. SHELTER AND- THOSE
LAWS MAY THREE COME MORE AND-
NOT ONLY HAVE THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS EXPERIENCE CRISIS
CALL DURING THIS TIME THEY ALSO
BECOME MORE RESPONSIBLE FOR. I
AM PROVIDING IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION TO BILLS WITH NO
SENSE OF DIRECTION ON. RESOURCE
SUCH AS ANGER MANAGEMENT
COUNSELING. THERE P. THOSE HAVE
OUR OWN. THEN THE MAIN ONES.
THAT NEEDS TO BE BACK AND TAX
TO HELP WITH MENTAL ISSUES
GOING ON PERFORMING ARTS CO IN.
NINETEEN OUR- DOMAIN THE MAIN
THING IS COMMUNICATION I FEEL
LIKE IS THE MAIN KEY. THAT WILL
HELP. THE HERB THAT WOULD HELP
PEOPLE DESK AND MY PREDICAMENT.
OVERCOME THESE OBSTACLES
BECAUSE- I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE RIGHT WITH ANYONE
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS LOCKED
DOWN YOU KNOW EVERYWHERE YOU GO
WE HAVE TO HAPPEN BASS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE SOME CREDENTIALS TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THOSE CREDENTIALS WE
PRETTY MUCH ON YOUR OWN. SO- I
JUST FEEL LIKE COMMUNICATING
AND. THAT'S THAT'S THE MAIN
THING TO HELP IN PAST THESE
DURING HIS COMPLIMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER WALTER HILL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- AND WE HEAR YOUR
VOICE WE HEAR OF. THE PASSION
THAT YOU HAVE WE WILL NOW GO TO
KALEENA FOWLER IS PRESENT IN
PERSON WITH THIS AS A SURVIVOR.
HELLO MY NAME IS CLEANER FOWLER
AND I'M CURRENTLY A SENIOR AND
TENDING COLLEGE PARK HIGH
SCHOOL IN PLEASANT HILL WHICH
IS IN THE COSTA COUNTY DISTRICT.
I AM HONORED TO BE SELECTED TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE STUDENTS
REGARDING THE IMPACT OF PROBE
IN NINETEEN ON THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH. I ENJOY ADVOCATING FOR
THE COMMUNITY HENCE WHY I AM AN
ACTIVE MEMBER IN THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB OF MARTINEZ. AS WELL
AS I'M THE PRESIDENT OF MY
SCHOOL'S BLACK STUDENT UNION.
THE BOX UNION I'VE CREATED
CLOSE KNIT COMMUNITY. WITH THE
HELP OF MY CLUB LEADERS. WE
ADVOCATE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
EQUALITY AND EQUITY IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY. NOT ONLY HAS
THE BOXING UNION. OPEN UP SO
MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME BUT
AS HELP ME INSPIRED TO GIVE
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY IMMENSELY.
IN ADDITION TO THE BOXING IN A
MEMBER OF MANY CLUBS SUCH AS BE
THE CHANGE IN IRAQ ROTARY AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CLUB. FURTHERMORE
I AM MY SCHOOL STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER. MY DUTIES REPRESENT AND
SPEAK ON BEHALF THE STUDENTS AS
WELL AS TO MAKE SURE THEIR
DESIRES ARE BROUGHT TO LIFE.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL I PLAN TO GO
STRAIGHT TO A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
AND STUDY POLITICAL SCIENCE
PUBLIC POLICY. FOLLOWING LAW
SCHOOL. MY ULTIMATE GOAL IN
LIFE IS ALWAYS ADVOCATE FOR
VOICES IN NEED. I WOULD COVER
NINETEEN HAS IMMENSELY IMPACTED
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS-
SPECIFICALLY STUDENTS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE PEOPLE'S ARE EITHER
EXCELLED IN THIS IS RUNNING FOR
COMPLETELY FELL APART. NOT
HAVING THE HANDS ON RESOURCES
TO GROWN SCHOOL PLUMMETED THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF STUDENTS THAT
TURNED OUR LIFE UPSIDE DOWN.
LEADING TO DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDE RATES GOING UP LOSS OF
SLEEP AND APPETITE. FEELING
ISOLATED ALONE. I WAS FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO HAVE THE ABILITY OF
TIME MANAGEMENT I WAS ABLE TO
THRIVE IN THIS AND STARTING. AS
WELL AS MY GREAT FAMILY HELPED
ME. REGARDING RESOURCES SOME OF
MY TEACHERS NOT VERY
ACCOMMODATING TO STUDENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE GETTING POP QUIZZES NOT
BEING ABLE TURN IN LATE WORK.
THE LACK OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY HAVE FOR US. WAS TERRIBLE.
ON THE OTHER HAND SO MY
TEACHERS RIVER ACCOMMODATING
THAT OFFICE HOURS HELP US CALM
LET US RETAKE TEST THEY
UNDERSTOOD HOW HARD IT WAS IN
THIS LIFE OF CHAOS. I BELIEVE
THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY REALLY
BENEFITTED. THE STUDENTS MORE
PACIFIC RESUME I'M NOT SURE HOW
WE WOULD HAVE LEARNED WITHOUT
ZOOM AND I'M REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. LEARNING THROUGH
SCREEN WAS IMMENSELY DIFFICULT
BUT- THE TEACHERS SOME WERE
COMING HAVE OFFICE HOURS AND
HAVING VISUALS AND POSTING
THEIR LECTURES TO LOOK BACK ON
WAS VERY. APPRECIATIVE AS ALSO
PHONE COMMUNICATIONS WITH
FRIENDS I FEEL HELPED TOUCH
KEEP US IN TOUCH WITH OUR
COMMUNITY. I GAVE US A TOUCH OF
THE REAL WORLD WHILE THE- WELL
THE ROLE WAS IN CHAOS. I
BELIEVE SERVICE PROVIDERS SUCH
AS SOON. WE'RE GREAT WE- EXCUSE
ME I BELIEVE SERVICE PROVIDERS
SUCH AS YOU HAVE AG STRAINS
MORE CRISIS BECAUSE DURING THIS
TIME. JIM PUBLIC TUTORING- ON
ALL MY TEXTBOOKS. ARE MENTAL
HEALTH- GREATLY BENEFITED FROM
IT THE COMMUNICATION WAS
AMAZING. IT PROVIDED US WITH A
SENSE OF REALISM. I BELIEVE
COUNSELORS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
THERE'S EXTREME SHORTAGE IN MY
DISTRICT MY DISTRICT. TEACHERS
AND TO BE MORE UNDERSTANDING
AND ACCOMMODATING TO STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND PLANNING LESSONS
MUSEUM. IT'S BEYOND CHALLENGING
BY HAVING POP QUIZZES NOT BEING
ABLE TRANSLATE WORK AND HAVING
FILES IS JUST AND JUST. THE
WORK WE'RE DOING DISTANCE
LEARNING WAS TREMENDOUS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR MANY STUDENTS TO
KEEP UP WITH INCLUDING MYSELF.
I BELIEVE THE BARRIERS THOUGHT-
EXISTED BUT LIMITED OUR EFFORTS
TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS FOR
COMMUNICATION. COMMUNICATION IS
KEY WHEN SUPPORTING SURVIVORS
AND THE BEST WAY TO REACH OUT
STUDENTS AND MY DISTRICT WE DO
A LOT OF RESOURCES BUT LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE NOT EDUCATED ABOUT
THEM. FOR INSTANCE OUR SCHOOL
ID CARDS DO YOU HAVE THE- THEY
DO OF THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION HOTLINE. THE
DISTRICT HEALTH SERVICE USE OUR
HOTLINE AND THE CRISIS HOTLINE.
AS WELL SOCIAL MEDIA IS A GREAT
WAY TO SPREAD THE INFORMATION
FOR THOSE IN NEED. I'VE DONE MY
RESURGENT ON INSTAGRAM THERE
ARE SOME ACCOUNTS SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA LET'S
TALK MENTAL HEALTH IN
ADVOCATING FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
AS WELL AS WATER THE PSYCH
CENTRAL RETHINK AND NONSTICK
MONTHS. I WE SOCIAL MEDIA
REALLY HELP STUDENTS IN NEED.
IT WAS A SENSE THAT WE'RE ALL
THERE AND CONNECTED GOING
THROUGH THE SAME THING AND I
WAS REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE IT. DURING THIS TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU POLLINA
VALOR AND NEXT WE HAVE WILLIAM
BUT SOME BURKE SURVIVOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR GRAYSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS WILLIAM WATSON BURKE
I'M A PROUD RESIDENT OF TRACY
AND A FORMER CITY COUNCIL
CANDIDATE- COUNCILMEMBER
CANDIDATE AND A PROUD KOREAN
AMERICAN. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ORGANIZING THIS
HEARING AND ALLOWING
INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS MYSELF TO
SPEAK ON THE INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE THAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AND HOW IT'S IMPACTED US. WHEN
THE WORLD SHUT DOWN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AGO TO COVER NINETEEN.
NEVER COULD I HAVE IMAGINED THE
HATE AND VITRIOL THAT WOULD BE
DIRECTED ASIAN AMERICANS. IT
SEEMS LIKE DAY AFTER DAY YOU
SEE ON TWITTER. TICK TOCK.
INSTAGRAM AND CABLE TELEVISION
STORIES OF PEOPLE OF ASIAN
DESCENT BEING ATTACKED. THEY
WEREN'T DOING ANYTHING THEY
WERE HURTING ANYONE. BUT THAT
DIDN'T STOP INDIVIDUALS FROM
BELIEVING THAT THEY HAD A RIGHT
TO HURT THEM. EARLIER THIS YEAR
I WITNESSED A VIDEO OF AN
ELDERLY CHINESE WOMAN WHO HAD
BEEN ATTACKED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
SHOULD A LARGE PURPLE BRUISE
OVER HER EYE AND WAS CRYING
WHILE HER ASSAILANT WAS
RECEIVING MERIT MEDICAL
ATTENTION. THE CRIES I HEARD IN
THE VIDEO STRUCK ME. I
IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT OF MY
GRANDMOTHER A KOREAN AMERICAN
IMMIGRANTS AND NOW IN OUR
EIGHTIES AND I COULDN'T BEAR
IMAGINING HER WALKING DOWN THE
STREET OR COMING OUT OF CHURCH
TO BE ATTACKS SIMPLY BECAUSE
SOMEONE SOCCER ASIAN FEATURES.
WHEN THE SHOOTING IN ATLANTA
HI. WHEN THE SHOOTING IN THE
ATLANTASUBURBS HAPPENED I
AGAIN HAD A SIMILAR RESPONSE
THIS TIME I THOUGHT OF MY MOM.
THOSE THE ONES WITH THE
SHOOTINGS OCCURRED LEVINE OR
OPERATED BY WOMEN OF ASIAN
DESCENT. WHO KNOWS OF ANOTHER
SHOOTING OR ANOTHER ATTACK
COULD OCCUR IN SIMILAR
LOCATIONS. AT AN ASIAN
SUPERMARKET. AT AN ASIAN
RESTAURANT. TO HAVE TO LIVE IN
FEAR THAT SOMETHING TERRIBLE
COULD HAPPEN TO MY FAMILY OR
MYSELF. SIMPLY BECAUSE WE LOOK
DIFFERENT OR THAT WE HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH OF IN
NINETEEN. IS DRAMATIC. IN THE
WAKE OF THAT SHOOTING I HELPED
ORGANIZE A VIGIL WITH FELLOW
ADVOCATES IN MY HOMETOWN OF
TRACY. TO RECOGNIZE THE
VIOLENCE BEING PERPETRATED
AGAINST PEOPLE OF ASIAN DESCENT.
WE HAD A SHOWING OF NEARLY
FIFTY PEOPLE AND PUTTING SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS OF OUR CITY
COUNCIL INTENDED. TO SHOW THAT
WE WOULD STAND UP TO ACCESS.
THESE ACTS OF VIOLENCE. AND
THEN WE ALSO SAW THE SHOOTING
AT THE BEAUTY CENTER IN SAN
JOSE. WHERE THE WHERE TO
RESIDENTS OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
LOST THEIR LIVES. INCLUDING A
SICK MAN FROM TRACY. WELL THE
VCA INCIDENT MAY NOT BE
CLASSIFIED A HATE CRIME WHEN I
HEARD THIS. ME AND MANY OTHERS
IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT OF WHEN A
SICK MAN WAS MURDERED IN TRACY
I ONE OF OUR PARKS TWO YEARS
AGO. I CAME OUT TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY MOURNING THE LOSS OF
ONE OF OUR OWN AND HEARD FROM
LEADERS. FROM ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO COMMUNITY LEADERS ON THE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO ADDRESS
THE RISING VIOLENCE. THE
TROUBLE WE FACE AS INDIVIDUALS
AS A RESULT OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE. IS ALSO FELT AS A
COMMUNITY. WE LIVE IN A
CONNECTED WORLD WHERE WE SEE
AND EXPERIENCE WHAT OUR FRIENDS
AND FAMILIES AND EVEN STRANGERS
SHARE. WE NO LONGER CAN IGNORE
THAT THE WORLD IS IN SILENT.
BUT WHEN AND THAT THE TRAUMA
ONE COMMUNITY EXPERIENCES IN
ONE PART OF THE WORLD CANNOT
RICOCHET AND TSUNAMI IN
TOMORROW. WE HAVE BEEN ILLIQUID
TO HANDLE THE IMPACTS THESE
DRAMATIC EVENTS HAVE ON US. WE
HAVE TO FOCUS ON HOW TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THESE EVENTS. BUT EVEN AFTER
YOU TURN EIGHTEEN DRAMATIC
EVENTS STILL IMPACT US. AT THE
VIGIL HONORING THE LIVES OF THE
SENATE THEY SHOOTING. WE HAD
ELECTED OFFICIALS COME UP AND
SPEAK ON HOW THESE INCIDENTS
NEED TO STOP. BUT I BELIEVE
THERE WAS AN ABSENCE IN THE
RESOURCES WE CAN TURN TO HANDLE
HOW WE FEEL AND HOW THESE
EVENTS IMPACT US. ESPECIALLY IN
THIS WORLD IMPACTED BY COVE IN
NINETEEN. I'M GRATEFUL FOR THIS
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE
STARTING ON HOW INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE AFFECTS US AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. ALL THE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY REFLECTS MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES I RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE OUT
THERE LIKE ME WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY WHAT WE'VE
WITNESSED AND EXPERIENCED. AND
IT IS MY HOPE THAT WE CAN
STREAMLINE AND MAKE IT EASIER
TO ACCESS RESOURCES SO THAT WE
CAN HEAL FROM THESE WOUNDS. OR
MENTAL HEALTH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BURKE AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
NOW HEAR FROM THE CENTER
DIRECTOR. FOR THE CENTRAL
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER BADLY ONLY.
HELLO MY NAME. HOW YOU DOING.
I'M DOING MY NAME IS NOT
ILLEGALLY S. I AM THE CENTRAL
CENTER DIRECTOR FOR THE CONTRA
COSTA FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER.
THE FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER IS A
ONE STOP CENTER FOR SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT CHILD ABUSE ELDER ABUSE
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING. I'D LIKE
YOU. TO IMAGINE SOMETHING WITH
ME. IMAGINE A WOMAN NAMED
HANNAH AND HAS TWO CHILDREN AND
SHE LIVES WITH HER BOYFRIEND IN
A TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT. IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. AND IT
WORKS AT A LOCAL RESTAURANT
MAKING MINIMUM WAGE AND HER
BOYFRIEND FREDDIE IS UNEMPLOYED
THEY HAVE ADDED A ROCKY
RELATIONSHIP HISTORY BUT I'VE
NEVER GOTTEN INTO ANY PHYSICAL
ALTERCATIONS. CAN YOU IMAGINE
THEM. NOW IT'S MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE PANDEMIC HITS
AND EVERYTHING SHUTS DOWN THE
RESTAURANT WHERE HANNAH IS
WORKING THE SCHOOL WHERE THE
KIDS GO EVERYTHING OVER THE
COURSE OF THE FIRST FEW WEEKS
OF THE SHELTER IN PLACE AND I'M
FRED GET INCREASINGLY MORE
STRESSED SHE ISN'T WORKING FOR
IT ISN'T WORKING THE KIDS ARE
AT HOME ALL THE TIME GOING TO
SCHOOL. ONZM ALL IN THEIR TINY
APARTMENT IN FROM THE STRESS OF
THE SITUATION FRED BECOMES
PHYSICALLY ABUSIVE TOWARDS YEAH.
IN AN EARLY THE CHILDREN
THEMSELVES ARE WITNESSING THIS
ABUSE BECAUSE THEIR HOME ALL
THE TIME. IN EARLY APRIL AND IT
DECIDES THAT IT'S NO LONGER
SAFE FOR HER OR HER CHILDREN TO
REMAIN IN THE HOME. AND SHE
TRIES TO REACH OUT TO THE COURT
TO FILE A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER. BUT THE
COURT IS SHUT DOWN TO THE
PUBLIC SHE CAN'T GET A HOLD OF
ANYONE. SHE TRIED CALLING A FEW
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE SHE WANTS
TO MEET IN A SAFE PLACE WITHIN
ADVOCATE. BUT MOST SERVICES ARE
BEING OFFERED REMOTELY AND SHE
DOES NOT HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
HAVE A PHONE CONVERSATION.
CANISTER DURATION SEEMS
HOPELESS WHEN THE PANDEMIC HIT
THE CONTRA COSTA FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER MADE THE DECISION TO
REMAIN OPEN TO THE PUBLIC FOR
CLIENTS LIKE ANNA. THE PANDEMIC
EXACERBATED THE VIEWS HANNAH
WAS EXPERIENCING AND IT MADE IT
MORE CHALLENGING FOR HER TO
ACCESS RESOURCES. OFFICIALS
WERE TELLING THE COMMUNITY TO
SHELTER IN PLACE BUT HOW CAN
YOU DO THAT IF YOUR HOME IS NOT
A SAFE PLACE. IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS CONTRA COSTA FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER HAS GROWN TO
THREE LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
CONTRA COSTA AND IS PARTNERED
WITH OVER SIXTY ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THAT'S THE KEY TO GETTING
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC IN
GETTING SURVIVORS THE HELP THEY
NEED COLLABORATION BETWEEN
COMMUNITY AGENCIES. A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WERE ALL
INVOLVED AB ONE GOAL. REDUCING
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE. HOLDEN
HAS NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BOTH
OUR CLIENTS AND THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THEM IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER SO ON INCREASE OF
CLIENTS BY 14% WE ALSO SAW AN
INCREASE IN THE SEVERITY OF THE
ABUSE THEY WERE EXPERIENCING.
86% OF OUR CLIENTS ARE WOMEN
70% OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE
CHILDREN AND MAKE UNDER TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH. OVER
65% OR BY PUMP. THE MOST
CRITICAL NEEDS THAT WE SAW
DURING THE PANDEMIC FROM OUR
CLIENTS RESTRAINING ORDER
ASSISTANCE MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELLING SUPPORT AND HOUSING
AND IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
SINCE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AYE
LAWYERS FOR FAMILY JUSTICE
PROGRAM HASASSISTED A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY BRIAN'S WITH
RESTRAINING ORDERS WE'VE
CONNECTED SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE CLIENTS MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. AGENCIES
WORKING WITH SURVIVORS NEED TO
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO RUN
PROGRAMS UCH AS THESE THEY ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF SURVIVORS THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TIM GRAYSON
EFFORTS FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WILL BE
RECEIVING A MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
NEXT YEAR TO SUPPORT THESE
ONGOING PROGRAMS. PANDEMIC HAS
IMPACTED IN A PERSONAL BUYERS
SURVIVORS IN THE WAY WE COULD
NOT HAVE IMAGINED. WE MUST
REMEMBER THE INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE. WHEN VIOLENCE HAPPENS IN
THE HOME IT IMPACTS ALL SECTORS
HEALTHCARE AGENCIES THE LEGAL
SYSTEM EDUCATION. IS CRITICAL
FOR CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT AGENCIES THAT SERVE
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS THROUGH FUNDING AND
ADVOCACY MEASURES I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE WITH
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. AND I HOPE TO
COLLABORATE MORE CLOSELY IN THE
FUTURE WITH OUR STATE
REPRESENTATIVES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NOT NEARLY AS THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE WILL NOW GO TO
JOANNA RUSS'S PROJECT SISTER
FAMILY SERVICES. HELLO EVERYONE
MY NAME IS JOHN A ROAST US IN
NINE HOTLINE START. UP PROJECTS
INSTAGRAM SERVICES. WE ARE
LOCAL RAPE CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
MISTER PART OF ELLIE AND SAM
REGIONAL COUNTY. A MAJORITY OF
THIS MISTER COME ONE OF ALL AND
WE'RE COMMUNITIES THAT INCLUDES
ALL CHILDREN WANT. UNDOCUMENTED
SURVIVORS LGBTQ RIGHTS MR. ALL
HAD A DIFFICULT TIME. FOR IT TO
WORK DISCLOSE THAT THEY HAVE SO.
BUT BECAUSE OF COMMON. HADN'T
EVEN MORE TO TIME. ORDING AND
ACCESS RESOURCES AND IS JOHN
TIMES. I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT
PRO MR BROWN'S. HAS STOPPED
PROVIDING PERSON TO SUPPORT
SURVIVORS ONE REPORTING TO LINE.
WHEN GOING TO COURT. WHEN
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF
MEDICAL WORK FOR. NOT ONLY THAT
BUT OUR OUTREACH DEPARTMENT HAS
FOUND WAYS TO PROVIDE
PRESENTATIONS ON SEXUAL ASSAULT
RESOURCES TO THE COMMUNITY EVEN
THROUGHOUT CORPORATE NINETEEN.
WE HAVE HAD CAMPUS ADVOCATE WHO
HAS STILL PROVIDE SERVICES WITH
STUDENT SURVIVORS AND MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE SURVIVORS MARC
NEEDY. ARE BEING HEARD AND ARE
BEING SUPPORTED. BECAUSE OF
COMMON NINETEEN WE HAVE SEEN A
DECREASE OF VOLUNTEER
ADVOCATES. BUT WE STILL HAVE
SEEN INCREASED NEED FOR
ADVOCATES IN OUR COMMUNITY. WE
HAVE TEAMED UP WITH FRIENDS
NURSE SPECIALIST TO RESPOND TO
CASES ON FOR THE SUPPORT
INCREASING SUPPORT FOR
SURVIVORS DURING THE FRIENDS OF
MEDICAL EXAM HAVING ADVOCATE
DURING THE FRIENDS GOAL MEDICAL
EXAM IS CRUCIAL IT'S THE FIRST
STEP IN HEALING. AND HAVING
ADVOCATE THERE TO HELP. GUIDE A
SURVIVOR IS ESSENTIAL. OTHER
CHALLENGES WE HAVE SEEN OUR
DURING THE COLD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. ARE WHAT MANY PEOPLE
HAVE MENTIONED EARLIER HELPING
SURVIVORS. IN RESTRAINING
ORDERS. OUT THE NEW FOR
PROCEDURES AND PROTOCOLS DURING
COVERT NINETEEN SO MANY
SURVIVORS GO OUT WITH
RESTRAINING ORDERS BECAUSE THE
PROCESS JUST TO COMPLICATED.
MORE COMPLICATED THAN USUAL.
NOT ONLY THAT ARE SURVIVORS
HAVE ALSO HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
IN AXIS OF THE COMPENSATION THE
COMPENSATION WAS CRUCIAL IN
GETTING THE ONES THAT THEY NEED
IN A TIMELY MANNER TO BE LUCKY.
TO HAVE OUR SAFETY. OUR CAMERAS
THEIR HOME AND OTHER NEEDS IS
JUST AND- NINETEEN SURVIVORS
HAD TO AND WHAT DID TIME. NOW
MORE THAN EVER SOME FOR BIG.
AND SUPPORTERS ISN'T. AS WE SEE
THESE NUMBERS. AND SEEN
SURVIVORS BASICALLY COMPORT AND
START RECORDING AGAIN KEEPS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO AYE
ROSES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND I
THINK WE HEARD SOMETHING OF A
VERY A THEME THROUGHOUT AND
THAT WAS THAT TECHNOLOGY PLAYED
A CRUCIAL ROLE. IN PEOPLE BEING
ABLE TO MAKE A CONNECTION-
HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW AND HAVE
EXPERIENCE THIS THAT THAT- IN
PERSON CANNOT BE REPLACED. AND
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE'S A
DYNAMIC THAT COMES WITH IN
PERSON WHETHER IT'S A MEDICAL
EXAM AND HAVING AN ADVOCATE
PRESENT OR WHETHER IT'S THAT
AND MISSIONAL ENGAGEMENT OR
CONTACT TO- TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. THAT IN PERSON-
ENGAGEMENT OF CONTACT IS
IRREPLACEABLE SO I'M GLAD FOR
THE TELEHEALTH I'M GLAD FOR
REMOTE ACCESS HOWEVER THERE ARE
SOME ASPECTS OF IN PERSON THAT
JUST CANNOT BE REPLACED SO WITH
THAT. WELL EITHER JOANNA WHAT
VERY. CURRENTLY EXIST THAT
LIMIT OR IMPEDE YOUR EFFORTS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT- TO
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE OR INTIMATE. PARTNER
VIOLENCE AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE ENCOURAGE
INDIVIDUALS WHO EXPERIENCE IPV
TO REACH OUT. AND JOANNA OR OR
NATALIE EITHER ONE OF YOU. YES
SURE SO OF PERSONALLY I HAVE
SEEN THAT SURVIVORS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO BASIC NEEDS LIKE.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LAPTOP I
OFTENTIMES ONE ON SOON TO SHOW
THEM HOW TO- FIVE GREAT THINGS
LIKE. COMPENSATION HOUSING
RESOURCES THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE
BASIC NEEDS RIGHT WHY FIGHT-
COMPUTERS OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
I'M STILL. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
JUST INNOVATIVE WAYS OF MEETING
WITH SURVIVORS WHILE STILL
MEETING- OPENING TEAM SAFETY
PROCEDURES IN PLACE HAS BEEN A
STRUGGLE BUT I THINK AGENCIES
LIKE PROJECTS AND STERN OTHERS
ARE REALLY COMING TOGETHER TO
FIND OUT HOW TO BRIDGE. THOSE
GAPS AND SUPPORT SURVIVORS.
THANK YOU. MADLY YEAH I'M NOT I
WOULD SAY THERE WERE A COUPLE
THINGS THAT HAVE REALLY IMPUTED
IN BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT
SURVIVORS DURING THE PANDEMIC
IT'S A LITTLE LESS SO NOW BUT I
THINK ONE MAJOR WHICH WE ALL
KNOW WHAT IT IS ESPECIALLY IF
YOU RUN A NONPROFIT IS FUNDING
RIGHT. ALL THE FUNDING THAT
KIND OF STOPPED WE HAD SOME
LOCAL FUNDS THAT YOU CAN KINDA
COLLECTOR S. RIGHT THERE WERE
SOME ACTION NEED FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE NOT
RECEIVING STIMULUS TRACKS TO BE
ABLE TO PAY RENT- THERE WAS
WHEN THE COURT SHUT DOWN OUR
COURT SYSTEM ISN'T ONLINE YET
AND SO THEY HAD TO KIND OF
SCRAMBLE TO CREATE A WAITED.
FILE RESTRAINING ORDERS WITHOUT
HAVING TO HAVE THE PUBLIC COME
IN PERSON SO THERE WERE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ASPECTS SYSTEM WIDE
THAT NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
LOOKED AT IN ORDER TO TRY AND
MAKE REMOTE- SERVICES EASIER TO
ACCESS FOR INDIVIDUALS BUT
AGAIN I THINK THE ONE THING
THAT WAS ESSENTIAL IS THAT
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
COUNTY AGENCIES LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTINUE TO CONNECT WITH EACH
OTHER TO GET UPDATES ON WHAT
WAS GOING ON- AND I THINK THAT
HAD THE MOST IMPACT IN TRYING
TO CONNECT SURVIVORS TO
RESOURCE JUST BECAUSE- IF WE
ALL HAVE THE SAME MESSAGING OF.
YOU CAN STILL REACH OUT TO US
REGARDLESS OF WHAT AGENCY YOU
YOU CONNECT WITH THAT'S THE
CHEAP YOU'RE GETTING THE SAME
MESSAGING AND THEN SOME MORE
SURVIVORS ARE GONNA BE. ABLE TO
KNOW THEIR SUPPORT SERVICES.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND I DO
WANT TO THANK MISTER HILL MISS
VALOR. MISTER MUTTS AND BERG
FOR SHARING YOUR PERSONAL
STORIES AS WELL AS
MISCELLANEOUS AND MISS ROSES
FOR YOUR AMAZING SUPPORT- THAT
YOU AND YOUR ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDE EVERY DAY TO SURVIVORS.
OF INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE AND
FOR PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT
TODAY'S HEARING I DO WANT TO
TRY TO OUR OUR THIRD AND FINAL
PANEL- JANET SAID LEAGUE
COMMISSIONER AN INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE OF THE SUB
COMMITTEE CHAIRED. LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION VANESSA
RUSSELL FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR LOVE NEVER FAILS.
MONICA WILSON MAYOR PRO TEM
CITY OF ANTIOCH. CHRISTIAN
COLON PUBLIC POLICY DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND TINA ROSE
AULUS POLICY ADVOCATE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. THAT
THAT'S A GOOD NUMBER OF
SPEAKERS FAR LAST PANEL AND I
WOULD JUST ASK YOU IF YOU'D BE
SO KIND. AS TO- KEEP YOUR
TESTIMONY WITHIN THE TIME
PARAMETERS THAT I THINK WE
HAVE. OUT OF THE FIVE WE HAVE.
ONE THAT IS IN PERSON. AND SO
WE WILL AGAIN THIS PANEL WILL
EXPLORE STRATEGIES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS GIVEN BY THE
RISE OF INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE
DURING THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND WE WILL HAVE
COMMISSIONER SAID LEE BEGAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN- MY
NAME AGAIN IS JOANNE ASSEMBLY I
AM THE CHAIR OF THE LITTLE HARD
WORK AT LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION INTERNET PARTNER
VIOLENCE. COMMITTEE FIRST I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO HAS
APPEARED AT THE HEARING- WITH
US TODAY I THINK THE TESTIMONY
HAS BEEN INVALUABLE AND VERY
HELPFUL AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO
TRY TO ADDRESS ANY OF THESE
ISSUES. SO- WITH THAT I ALSO-
AS STATED BY CHAIRMAN ALTHOUGH
WHO- TESTIFIED ON YOUR FIRST
HAND ALL. THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION IS AN INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT AGENCY RESPONSIBLE
FOR INVESTIGATING EIGHT
OPERATIONS AND MAKING OF THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO IMPROVE
THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS. OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. MISSION ISSUE TO
WORK AND PAST YEAR AND- THIS
FIRST TO IN PARTNER VIOLENCE.
TRAGICALLY THIS IMPORTANT TO BE
USED IT CALLED IS A COMMON
EXPERIENCE FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS. THIRD OF WOMEN AT
A CORNER OF MEN IN CALIFORNIA
WILL EXPERIENCE INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE IN THEIR
LIFETIME WE CAN'T EVEN HIGHER
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THOSE
WHO ARE TRANSGENDER. STATE BANK
OF THIS HORRIFIC VIOLENCE ALL
OF IT GOES FOR THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES. IN OUR REPORT BE
ON THE CRISIS A LONG TERM
APPROACH TO REDUCE PREVENT AND
RECOVER FROM INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. WE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT HELP FROM
REACHING INDIVIDUALS AFFECTED
BY THIS HORRIFIC EXPERIENCE.
FIRST CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO
INTIMATE PARTNER PARTNER
VIOLENCE IS MINISTERED
FRAGMENTOS. THERE ARE DOZENS OF
STATE AGENCIES THAT ADDRESSES
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THIS CRISIS
BUT THERE IS NO SINGLEAGENCY
NOR SINGLE PERSON RESPONSIBLE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS OR
LACK THEREOF ON REDUCING OR
PREVENTING THIS TYPE OF CRIME.
THIS SILO APPROACH CREATES
CRITICAL GAPS IN THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO PREVENT THAT THE B.
S. AND THE BIGGEST PAY A PRICE.
THAT CALIFORNIA VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY OUR GREATEST
INTERVENTION WHICH MEANS HELP
IS OFTEN TOO LATE. OR TOO
LITTLE. EXISTING REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE TO
EVERYBODY. BATTERER
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS WERE
CONVICTED ABUSERS MUST
PARTICIPATE AS A CONDITION OF
PROBATION ARE NOT ARE WIDELY
AVAILABLE NOR ARE THEY DIVERSE.
WE'VE BEEN RURAL AREAS WHERE
SPEAK LANGUAGES OTHER THAN
ENGLISH YOU KNOW I HAVE MANY
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO FIND
SUITABLE PROGRAMS. AND NO
TAXPAYER FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. THE REQUIRED TO
PAY APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER PROGRAM DEPENDING ON THEIR
INCOME SLIDING SCALE. THOSE WHO
CANNOT PAY TOO MANY CLASSES ARE
OFTEN RE ARRESTED AND SPENT TEN
TO THIRTY DAYS IN JAIL FOR
VIOLATING PROBATION OFTEN
LOSING THEIR JOBS AND ACCRUING
EVEN MORE FINE AND MORE DEBT IN
THIS PROCESS. THIRD
CALIFORNIA'S GOT ALONG. WHICH
ARE DESIGNED TO DO A MEDIUM WE
REMOVE FIREARMS FROM ABUSE FROM
ABUSERS. LACKING FOR SMITH.
DECADES OLD USED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO TRACK INDIVIDUALS
PROHIBITED FROM YOU OWNING GUNS
ARE UNABLE TO AUTOMATICALLY
CROSS REFERENCE EACH OTHER AN
OLDER AGENT INTERNATIONAL
PHONE- SO MAY NO LONGER BE
ELIGIBLE. VOTER WEAPON. TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE THE DOJ FACES A
CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF SPECIAL
AGENTS TO CARRY OUT WHAT IS
VERY VERY DANGEROUS WORK OF
LOCATING AND RETRIEVING THESE
WEAPONS. IT IS A LOT OF THEIR
STATE A WOMAN IS FIVE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE KILLED BY AN
ABUSIVE PARTNER. IF THAT
GENTLEMAN HAD ACCESS TO
FIREARMS. THAT IS NOT ALLOWED
TO HAVE. LASLEY A LACK OF LONG
TERM SUPPORT FIRST MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO ESTABLISH
A LIFE ON THEIR OWN. ECONOMIC
INDEPENDENCE IS THE KEY FOR
SURVIVORS TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY LEAVE AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP BUT SADLY MANY
COULD NOT AFFORD TO STAY AWAY
FROM THEIR ABUSER. SURVIVORS
OFTEN DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR OWN BANK ACCOUNTS OR
VITAL DOCUMENTS THAT THEY NEED
IN ORDER TO TRAVEL FOR SECURITY
JOB HOUSING OR FINANCIAL AID.
CURRENTLY STATE RESOURCES ARE
NOT AS HELPFUL TO SURVIVORS AS
THEY SHOULD BE WELL THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD REIMBURSES
CRIME VICTIMS FOR DIRECTING THE
DENNIS EXPENSES RELATED TO THIS
CRISIS MANY SURVIVORS DO NOT
HAVE THE FUNDS AVAILABLE TO PAY
FIRST FOR THE SERVICES. AND
WAIT. UNTIL THEY CAN BE
REIMBURSED. AN EMERGENCY A-
WELCOME. IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
HELP SURVIVORS OF INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE ACHIEVE LONG
TERM STABILITY. SURVIVORS OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE CAN
BE BETTER HELP IF CALIFORNIA
ACTS NOW JUST OVERCOME THESE
BARRIERS. IN THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION'S REPORT. THAT
OUTLINED KEY STEPS THAT THE
STATE CAN TAKE COULD YOU JEFF
THAT. CALIFORNIA MUST FIRST BE
TRANSFORMED ITS RESPONSE TO
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE FROM
A FOCUS ON CRISIS INTERVENTION
IS TO ONE OF PREVENTION. AND
EARLY INTERVENTION. WELL CRISIS
IS A CRITICAL ASPECT OF
RESPONDING TO INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. IT COULD NOT. PURSUED
IT ALONE. THE STATEMENT ALSO
FOCUS ON PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES TO MAKE
TO MAKE AVAILABLE HELP
AVAILABLE FOR THE CRISIS
ARRIVED. FURTHER THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE MUST
APPOINT A LEADER WHO ILL NOT
ONLY ONLY ISSUE AREA
ADVANCEMENT PARTNER VIOLENCE
BUT WILL ALSO STEER THE STATE
TOWARDS A NEW APPROACH. THE
LEGISLATURE MUST ALSO ENSURE
THE CREATION AND FUNDING OF
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM IS
INITIATIVE SHOULD BE INCLUDED
AND ALL APPLICABLE STATEWIDE
STRATEGIC PLANS RANGING FROM
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION YOUR
REDUCING. HOMELESSNESS EXISTING
WAY OF. PRO THAT BETTER URBAN
PROGRAMS SHOULD BE A- ON
WHETHER THEY ARE ACTUALLY.
REHABILITATION OR NOT. YEAH THE
LEGISLATURE MUST ENFORCE THE
STATE'S FIREARMS LAWS- SPEEDING
UP BY G. MODERNIZATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND BOLSTERING
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
SPECIAL AGENT. WILL HELP
TOWARDS THIS REALITY. FINALLY
RESOURCES THAT HELP SURVIVORS
ESTABLISH FINANCIAL
INDEPENDENCE MUST BE EXPANDED
AND PROMOTED THIS INCLUDES
CREATING A ONE STOP SHOP WHERE
SURVIVORS CAN RECEIVE COPIES OF
THEIR VITAL RECORDS AS WELL AS
INFORMATION ON HOW TO RECOVER-
AND THAT RECOVER AND PREVENT
IDENTITY BACK. TRANSITIONING
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
MODEL FROM A STATE FUNDED ONE
OF REIMBURSEMENT SO REAL TIME
PAYMENTS WILL BE VERY HELPFUL
AND- ADVERTISING HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE TO
SURVIVORS- TO SURVIVORS MORE
FULLY AND EJECTING THAT
FLEXIBLE- TO BE MORE FLEXIBLE
TWO SURVIVORS NEEDS ALL THE
HELP TO SOLVE THESE ISSUES.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ONCE
IMPLEMENTED WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA TO CREATE A MORE
HOLISTIC STRATEGIC AND
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
COMBAT INTERNET PARTNER
VIOLENCE AND HELPING SURVIVORS
THEREBY THE SURVIVING. ON THEIR
OWN. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU DO YOU THANK YOU JEFF
SAID LEE AND WILL NOW GO TO
VANESSA. FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR LOVE NEVER FAILS. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR FOR A
CHAIRMAN GRAYSON AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AND THE
YELLOW HIGH COURT LEADERSHIP
TEAM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE OF
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- I AM THE
FOUNDER OF LOVE NEVER FAILS AN
ANTI TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATION
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR TEN
YEARS. I WE PROVIDED HOUSING
FOR A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
WOMEN MEN AND CHILDREN AND WE
ALSO HAVE A STATE CERTIFIED
CYBERSECURITY AND NETWORKING
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS AND
OTHER VULNERABLE POPULATIONS-
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE TRAINED
OVER THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS-
USING OUR I. T. CURRICULUM. AND
OUR STUDENTS ARE 56% WOMEN AND
68% BLACK AND LATINO I SHOULD
ALSO MENTION I'M ALSO THE CO
CHAIR OF OAKLAND'S VIOLENCE
PREVENTION COALITION GENDER
BASED VIOLENCE COMMITTEE. AND
ALSO A PROFESSOR ANDREFERRAL
TO COLLEGES IN OAKLAND AND VERY
ADAMANT ABOUT WORKING WITH.
VICTIMS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE GENDER BASED VIOLENCE
AND PROVIDING THEM ACCESS TO
SUSTAINABLE CAREERS IN THE IT
WORLD. WE BELIEVE THAT THE LACK
OF HOUSING SUSTAINABLE CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES AND MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ARE THE
GREATEST BARRIERS THAT WE HAVE
AND THE SERVICES THAT ARE
NEEDED- THAT TO OVER COMMON
PREVENT. AND INTERVENE IN THE
LIVES OF. HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS AND- A QUICK STORY IN
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY I RECEIVED
A CALL FROM VALLEJO PD AND
LETTING ME KNOW THAT THEY HAD A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD IT WAS A RAINY
NIGHT AND SUNDAY NIGHT.
MIDNIGHT ARE THEY HAD A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD AND THEY DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE TO TAKE HER ON SHE HAD
BEEN TRAFFICKED OUT OF CARS.
AND FOR SIX MONTHS AND THERE
SHE WAS AND NEEDED SOMEWHERE TO
GO. I WENT TO GO PICK HER UP.
AND AND I STARTED CALLING
AROUND TO MY CONTACTS DURING
THE THIS IS YOUR AGAIN MAY
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE MIDDLE THE
PANDEMIC. STARTED CALLING THE
PLACES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE CHILDREN
AND THAT I HAD LOOKED TO FOR AS
FOR PARTNER HAS ME AS A PARTNER
IN THIS DIFFICULT SITUATION.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THEY HAD ALL
CLOSED. AND SO I FOUND MYSELF
IN A REALLY ON A HARD PLACE.
FORTUNATELY I WAS ABLE TO GET
IN TOUCH WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. AND ALSO WITH THE
YOUTH SHELTER IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO HOUSE HER
FOR NINETY DAYS. USUALLY IT'S A
TWENTY ONE DAY HOLD BUT I'M FOR
YOUTH AND HOMELESS YOUTH BUT IT
HAD BEEN EXTENDED TO NINETY
DAYS DURING THAT THE CAN
DAMAGE. AS I LOOKED AROUND-
JUST AROUND THE STATE. AFTER
THAT WE REPLACED HER I. WAS
LOOKING FOR PLACES THAT SHE
COULD GO THAT WEREN'T LONG TERM
AND AGAIN COULD NOT FIND ANY
PLACES FOR TRAFFICKED GIRL TO
GO. AND THAT WAS THAN WE WERE
WHEN WE MADE THE PLANS TO OPEN
OUR HOME. IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOR GIRLS AGES THIRTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN- AND THIS PLACE
THIS HOME THAT WE'VE OPENED. A
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HOUSE FIVE
GIRLS AND PROVIDE THEM SAFETY.
AND A PLACE FOR HEALING AND
ALSO A PLACE WHERE THEIR
PARENTS CAN RECEIVE COUNSELING
AND REUNIFICATION SUPPORT- AND
THE REASON I BRING THIS UP IS-
WE HAVE NOTICED A AN EXTREME
SHORTAGE OF HOUSING FOR ADULTS.
FOR WOMEN I'M FOR- LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR MEN AND
FOR GIRLS AND FOR BOYS THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY. A GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE IMPACTED BY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AND THIS GIRL WAS
JUST ONE OF MANY THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN TURNED PERHAPS RIGHT
BACK OUT ON THE STREET IF A
PARENT DIDN'T PICK THEM UP. OR
PERHAPS MAYBE A PARENT WOULD
CALM BUT A PARENT WHO WAS
LIVING IN CAR POVERTY
APPARENTLY WAS TRAUMATIZED
APPARENTLY WAS ILL EQUIPPED. TO
DEAL WITH THE CHILD HAD BEEN
SEXUALLY TRAUMATIZED IN THAT
WAY. AND SO. WE BELIEVE AGAINST
THEM EARLY IN OUR XIN ISN'T
MUCH NEEDED- AT AS WE GO FOR.
AND LOOK AT THE IMPACTS OF
THINGS LIKE THE PANDEMIC AND
JUST IN GENERAL. FINDING WAYS
TO HOUSE TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. FOR THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IS KEY
TO PREVENTING. THE EXTENSION OF
A GENDER BASED VIOLENCE OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND OF A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I ALSO WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT- VERY QUICKLY I
WANT TO THANK BOTH CHAIR
PERSON- GRAYSON AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER FOR YOUR
ABSTAINED. AND OR OPPOSE BOTH
FOR THE SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH IS AN ATTEMPT TO
DECRIMINALIZE LOITERING FOR
PROSTITUTION ACROSS THE STATE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU BECAUSE
IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU'RE
LISTENING TO SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHO ARE SAYING.
THAT LEGISLATION LIKE THIS-
THAT IS SEEMS TO BE A POSITIVE
THING FOR VICTIMS- IS ACTUALLY.
GOING TO BE QUITE DETRIMENTAL
TO THEM- BECAUSE ON ONE HAND
SURVIVORS WANT TO SEE THE
DECRIMINALIZATION. OF HIM OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING- AND BECAUSE
THEY ARE VICTIMS THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE CRIMINALIZED BUT-
BILLS LIKE THIS TO
DECRIMINALIZE IT THE CRIME FOR
BUYERS. AND FOR EXPLOITERS AND
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE VERY
ADAMANT ABOUT I'M KIND OF
ADVOCATING AGAINST WE ALSO WANT
TO SEE. BILLS LIKE THIS COM
COUPLED WITH NOT PROVIDING
SERVICES LIKE THE HOUSING LIKE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES LIKE
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES THAT. THAT WE OFFER
AND MANY OTHER NONPROFITS IN
ADVOCATES OFFER WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE SERVICES ARE
OFFERED AS- AS- REASONABLE EXIT
SERVICES. FROM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING- IF THERE'S EVEN A
POSITION OF REMOVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR REMOVING THE
CURRENT PROTECTION AND GATES
THAT ARE IN PLACE. THERE NEEDS
TO BE AN ALTERNATIVE PUT IN
PLACE AND SO VERY ADAMANT THAT-
AS WE LOOK AT NOT ONLY THE-
SERVICES LANDSCAPE BUT WE LOOK
AT THE POLITICAL. AND POLICY
LANDSCAPE THAT WE KEEP THE
SURVIVOR VOICE. FRONT. AND
CENTER AND I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT
YOU HAD SOME VIRUS ON EARLIER
TODAY PRIORITIZING THEIR FOR.
THEIR THEIR NEEDS AND- LASTLY I
WILL SAY THAT DURING THE PAN
TAPE BAND TO MAKE WE HAVE SEEN
AN UPTICK IN THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY. FOR EXPLOITING
CHILDREN- I BELIEVE I HEARD
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY SITE THAT THERE WERE
YOU KNOW ELEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE ADDS THAT SHE WHERE
SHE AN- ENTERTAINMENT AND SERVE
THAT 70% OF WHOM WERE UP OR UP
ADS OF PEOPLE THAT WERE UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY. WE KNOW
THAT- TECHNOLOGY IS BEING USED
IN A VERY POSITIVE WAY AS WITH-
HAVE MENTIONED EARLIER TO-
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS PUT IN PLACE WITH
TECHNOLOGY- SUCH AS- WHAT WE'RE
SEEING COMING UP HERE VERY
QUICKLY WITH THE ONLY FANS-
ONLINE PLATFORM WHICH IS BEING
USED TO TRAFFIC CHILDREN. AND
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS THAT
THOSE TYPES OF A- PLATFORMS BE
CAREFULLY MONITORED AND
CAREFULLY- CAREFULLY MANAGED
AND- AND THAT. THE ONLINE WORLD
AS WE BRING MORE CHILDREN ON TO
THE ONLINE WORLD AND WE BRING
MORE VULNERABLE PEOPLE ON THERE
THAT THEY'RE NOT PREYED UPON
THAT THEY HAVE THE PROPER
TRAINING AND THAT THERE IS A
PROPER. SAFETY PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DIGITAL WORLD IS A SAFE PLACE
FOR THEM AS WELL SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AGAIN TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
SURVIVORS. AND- THANKS FOR THIS
FOR THIS TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY VANESSA RUSSELL
AND WE WILL NOW. GO TO SENATE
OR TO- MONICA WILSON MAYOR PRO
TEM. FOR CITY OF ANTIOCH. YES
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON GRAYSON-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF GOOD
INFORMATION- THIS AFTERNOON
AFTER THAT ACTUALLY THIS
MORNING SO I'M GONNA KEEP MY
COMMENTS. BRIEF BECAUSE A LOT
OF IT IS REPETITIVE BUT I'M I'M
JUST GONNA GET STRAIGHT O THE
POINT. MY NAME IS MONICA WILSON
AND I'M THE MAYOR PRO TEM OF
ONE OF THE LARGEST ONE OF THE
LARGEST CITIES IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. THE CITY OF ANTIOCH.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPACE TO TESTIFY AND PROVIDE A
VOICE FOR THOSE IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT FEEL THAT THEY
ARE NOT HEARD. BY BEING HERE
TODAY WE'RE LETTING SURVIVORS
KNOW THAT THEY THAT THEY MATTER
AND THAT THEY ARE NOT ALONE.
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE I'VE DEVOTED MYSELF TO
THE VOCATION. OF PROVIDING
SUPPORT TO SURVIVORS. OF BOTH
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. FOR MANY OF US THE
IDEA OF BEING AN ABUSIVE
PARTNER MAKES ABSOLUTELY BEING
WITH AN ABUSIVE PARTNER MAKES
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ASKING WHY THEY STAY.
IF ONLY THAT WERE TRUE AND THAT
SIMPLE. HOWEVER THE REASON THAT
MANY SURVIVORS REMAIN SILENT
AND IN THE SHADOWS FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME IS BECAUSE THE
ABUSE ISN'T JUST PHYSICAL IS
ALSO EMOTIONAL. IT IS TO THAT
EMOTIONAL SKEWS ME ABUSE THAT
ABUSER CAN CREATE A CAGE BY
WHICH THE VICTIM FEELS THAT SHE
OR HE CANNOT ESCAPE- MY WILL DO
MY WORK I'VE LEARNED THAT THE
KEY TO GETTING A SURVIVOR TO
LEADER SITUATION IS CREATING A
SUPPORT SYSTEM. AROUND THEM
THAT GIVES THEM THE CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY WILL BE PROTECTED
ONCETHEY LEAVE THEIR
SITUATION. EMPIRE PROTECTED I
DO NOT JUST MEAN MORAL SUPPORT.
I MEAN LONG TERM HOUSING WHICH
SEEMS TO BE A CONSTANT COMING
UP DUE OUT TODAY LEARNING
SKILLS TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES AND THEIR CHILDREN
TO OBTAIN CAREERS THAT PAY A
LIVABLE WAGE. LEGAL SUPPORT AND
COUNSELING TO HELP SURVIVORS
REHABILITATE THEIR INNER SELF
AND DO THAT REHABILITATION
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF REGAINING
THEIR VOICE. YOU CAN ARREST AND
YOU YOU CAN ARREST AN ABUSER
EVERY SINGLE TIME BUT IT WILL
NOT CHANGE ANYTHING BECAUSE THE
MOMENT THE ABUSER IS RELEASED
THEY WERE RELY ON THE MENTAL
HOLD THEY HAVE ON THE VICTIM TO
REGRETREGAIN CONTROL OVER THAT
PERSON'S LIFE. BY BREAKING THE
METAL HOLD WE CAN BREAK THE
ENTIRE CYCLE AND ALLOW VICTIMS
THE CONFIDENCE THEY NEED TO
BREAK AWAY AND THRIVE I THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM
MIKE WILSON AND I KNOW
PERSONALLY FIRSTHAND. YOUR
PASSION IN THE SUBJECT AREA AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR GOOD
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO CHRIS TO COLON-
POLICY. DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER PRECIADO YOU
HOSTING THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
SESSION. OF MY NAME IS KRISTA
COLOGNE I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. WE ARE THE STATEWIDE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COALITION
WHICH MEANS THAT I HAVE THE
TREMENDOUS PRIVILEGE IN HONOR
OF WORKING EVERY DAY WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE
PROVIDERS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE- PREVIOUS
PAST. MANY MONTHS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT KOBE AND AS
PRESENTED IN THEIR WORK SOME OF
WHICH YOU HAVE HEARD
HIGHLIGHTED ALREADY BY STATE
SPEAKER- SO I'LL IRATE. NO MOVE
INTO SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ONE.
OF ON THE GROUND US AN INSIGHT.
VIOLENCE IS A PANDEMIC IN THE
STATE LONG BEFORE CO EFFORT BY-
THE NEEDS AND CHALLENGES. OF
SURVIVORS PREDATE. AND WELCOME
TO ON PAST THE FANDOM WITH
ACTION WHICH WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AS THE STATE TO BE
ABLE. I'M COMING HOUSE OF
COURSE EXACERBATED MANY OF THE
IS NEEDED HIGHLIGHTED
DISPARITIES- HERE WITH OUR
STATE THAT DEMAND OUR ATTENTION
AND THE URGENCY OF OUR ACTION.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT US TO
KEEP IN MIND AND THE STATE THAT
I WAS BE HOPEFULLY COME TO AN
END OF CONVINCING. AS
VACCINATION RATES INCREASE IF
THIS CONTINUES TO DECLINE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AT THE END OF
COALBED ON SURVIVORS WILL BE
FELT LONG AFTER. WE KNOW THAT
THE TRAUMA SURVIVORS ARE
EXPERIENCING DURING THIS TIME
WILL TAKE TIME TO HEAL FROM THE-
UNCERTAIN DEMAND FOR SUPPORT
AND SERVICES AND HOUSING AND
ACCESS. TO OUR COURTS WILL
CONTINUE. I'M JUST THE SUMMER
WHEN WE THOUGHT WE HAD TURNED A
CORNER AND SEE A REAL CHANGE-
ONE OF LOCAL PROGRAM SHARED
WITH ME THAT IN THE FIRST FIVE
DAYS OF THE MONTH THEY DID AS
MANY LEGAL IN TEXAS THAT WOULD
TYPICALLY DO IN A FULL THIRTY
DAY AND- I'M SO WE KNOW THAT AS
WE CONTINUE TO LOOSEN
RESTRICTIONS SURVIVORS ARE
COMING FORWARD LOOKING FOR.
SUPPORT SO IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE AT THE STATE LEVEL ARE THERE
TO SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORT SURVIVORS FOR THE
DURATION. AND OF COURSE ONE OF
THOSE KEY AREAS OF SUPPORTER IS
IN THE REALM OF HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. YOU HEARD ALREADY
FROM SO MANY OF THE SPEAKERS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF HOUSING
SO I'M NOT GOING TO REITERATE
THAT. BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS IN
WHICH WE HAVE THE STATE CAN DO
BETTER. I'M TOO OFTEN WHEN THE
STATE CONVERSATIONS CENTER ON
HOMELESSNESS AND THE INCREDIBLE
NEED TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IN
THE STATE. A DISCUSSION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND FRANKLY
ON WOMEN'S EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS IS LEFT OUT OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. ALTHOUGH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF WOMEN'S
HOMELESSNESS AND ALTHOUGH BY
DEFINITION DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTERS ARE HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS. ARE HOMELESSNESS
SYSTEM CAN CONTINUE TO DO
BETTER AT RECOGNIZING. SECTION
INCLUDING ENSURING EXPLICIT
REFERENCE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN THE PROGRAM SERVING
SURVIVORS IN ANY OF OUR BUDGETS
AND FUNDING- APPLICATIONS. OUT
FROM THE STATE- INCLUDING
DEDICATED FUNDING EXPLICITLY
WITHIN THE HOMELESSNESS BUDGET-
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I WAS
SAYING THAT WHEN REALIZE D.
WITH THE HOMELESSNESS. WHICH
WAS SO OFTEN- THE PHONE SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE PER. FROM PROVIDE
PERSON DONE AND- IN ORDER TO
PROTECT SURVIVORS WE PROTECT
SURVIVOR CONFIDENTIALITY BY NOT
PROVIDING INTENDS PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION ABOUT
THEM IS MASSIVE DATABASE. AND
SO FOR OUR CITY IS COUNTY IS
THAT OUR STATE LEVEL TO WORK
WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO DO
COLLECTS TREMENDOUS INFORMATION
THAT IS HELPFUL IN
DEMONSTRATING HOW THEY ARE
MEETING OUR HOMELESSNESS
SCHOOLS. HOW THEY ARE SERVING A
KEY PORTION OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION. I'M TO MAKE SURE
THE BACK CORPORATE AND BECAUSE
WE KNOW WITH THE DATA BECAUSE
COUNTY BUT AT. WHAT WE FOCUS ON
AND SO IF WE LEAVE OUT THE
NEEDS OF VICTIMS SERVICE
PROVIDERS SURVIVORS THIS ORDER.
WILL CONTINUE TO BEST. THIS
CONGRESS ON HOW ON THE
INTERNATIONAL ONE OF SHARE SOME
DEEP. TO THE- I'M FUNDED
THROUGH VICTIMS FOR TO HELP WE
HAVE ONE OF THE MANY PROGRAMS
CALLED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOUSING FIRST WHICH IS
PROVIDING FLEXIBLE FINANCIAL
SYSTEM ALMOST AS PREVENTION
RAPID RE HOUSING FOR SURVIVORS
AND HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL. FORTUNATELY IT'S
LARGELY FULLY FUNDED THROUGH
FEDERAL DOLLARS WHICH HAD BEEN
DECLINING PRECIPITOUSLY AND
THIS YEAR THE STATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE REALLY HEARD US AS WE
REACTED TO NEWS THAT- SERVICE
PROVIDERS MAY BE FACING
SIGNIFICANT COSTS OF US DOLLAR.
AND THE STATE BUDGET THAT WAS
PASSED THE SUMMER INCLUDED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO HOLD
BACK FILL THOSE CUTS WHICH HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS BREATH OF
FRESH AIR IN THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS BROUGH THE LITTLE
EASIER KNOWING THAT THIS MODEL
THEIR MERGING SEA SHELTERS SO
MANY OTHER PIECES OF THEIR WORK
WE'RE NOT GOING TO. BE THE ONE
REALLY APPRECIATE- BOTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON AND THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE. UP WORK. BUT OF
COURSE WE CAN'T ABOUT HOW- OR
NOT ANNOUNCER TALK ABOUT PART.
AND THE CHAO OF IF HOUSING THE
STATE. AND ECONOMIC. HUGE CAR
OF THE THAT DO CONTINUE TO HEAR
AND SEE. RIGHT HEARD FROM SPEAK
ALL. ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES. AND THEIR WAYS FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
THE LEGISLATURE HAS A PENDING
TO YOUR BILL WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS THAT SB THREE SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR DAVE VAN WHICH
ADDRESSES DEBT COLLECTION
AGAINST SURVIVORS FOR DEBTS
THAT THEY DID NOT KNOW WERE
TAKEN OUT THEIR NAME OR
POLITICAL WORST INTO TAKING
OUT- BECAUSE OF THE ABUSE THEY
WERE EXPERIENCING. REDUCING
THAT. AS THE FORD BASICALLY.
BUT WE CAN ALSO DO MORE TO
IMPROVE OUR CALVET SYSTEM AND
HOW IT RESPONDS TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AGUIAR-CURRY AND ALSO
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING PROPERTY INCLUDING
SURVIVORS WHO MAY NOT SELF
IDENTIFY WITH THE COLORS
PROCESS WITHIN A IN FACT ARE
GOING. TO BE. I'M CONTINUE
ATTENTION ONIONS LIKE CHILD
CARE WHICH IS A TREMENDOUS NEED
FOR SURVIVORS ESPECIALLY CHILD
CARE THAT'S AVAILABLE OUTSIDE
OF THE NINE TO FIVE MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY WORK WEEK. WE
CAN ALSO DO MORE TO EMPHASIZE
THINGS LIKE FLEXIBLE FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS DIRECTLY TO SURVIVORS
TO HELP THEM MEET THEIR
FINANCIAL NEEDS. AND INCREASING
GENERAL BENEFITS THROUGH THINGS
LIKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE- IT SIX
STATUS BROAD RANGE. FOR THOSE
THAT SUPPORTS CAN NOT ONLY HELP
TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS WHO ARE
HEALING FROM THE PACIFIC
EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO CAN
GENERALLY WORK TO REDUCE THE
POSSIBILITY OF VIOLENCE EVER
OCCURRING. AS WE REDUCE
ECONOMIC STRESS AND OUR FAMILY
IS REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF YOU.
I LOVE. YOU START TO WRAP UP TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO REALLY
PROVIDE SOME DEEP APPRECIATION
OF THE SERVICE PROVIDERS ACROSS
THE STATE. THERE ARE THE
EPITOME OF AN ESSENTIAL WORK
FOR. THEIR WORK NEVER STOPPED
THE CRISIS LINE CONTINUED TO
RING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN- AND
THEY HAVE PROVIDED SERVICES
BOTH REMOTELY AS YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE ADAPTATION BUT ALSO
IN PERSON DESPITE THE RISKS
THAT IN PERSON SERVICES
CONTINUES TO BRING TO THEIR OWN
PERSONAL HELP AND SEE. I FOR
PROGRAM OF THEIR STRONG RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE STRUGGLING BURNOUT
AND STRUGGLING WITH THE
VICARIOUS TRAUMA THEIR
EXPERIENCING. THEY'RE
STRUGGLING WITH THE LOW OKAY
THAT THEY ARE CONSTRAINED BY
BECAUSE OF THEIR BUDGETS GRANTS
ABOUT. STRUGGLING WITH HIGHER-
AND WE KNOW WE CAN'T SUPPORT
SURVIVORS WITHOUT THE STAFF
THERE YES PROGRAM. FINALLY FOR
ALL THAT WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT
THE HARMS OF THE IMMENSE TRAUMA
THAT SURVIVORS HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING. WE BELIEVE OUR
BELIEF THAT THIS IS NOT
AVAILABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
THAT IT IS TIME FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS AND ON
PREVENTION. RIGHT FOR EVERY
EVERY HARM THAT THIS HAPPENED
WE KNOW THAT WE CAN PREVENT US
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS- I WANT
TO APPRECIATE AGAIN IN THIS
YEAR'S STATE BUDGET THERE WAS
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
PREVENTION. WHICH IS THE
HIGHEST I'VE EVER SEEN. AND IT
IS STILL NOT ENOUGH AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT IS NOT GOING. SO
WELL THAT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WILL SUPPORT PROGRAMS
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS. OF
GRAHAM WHAT WE NEED AS LONG
TERM ONGOING- PREVENTION AT.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
SUPPORT PREVENTION BY HELPING
SUPPORT SOME SHIFTS IN SOCIETY
OF ALL CONDITIONS SUCH AS
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT CHANGE IN
OUR SOCIAL NORMS THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS MENTION
OF POSSIBLE WE'RE COMING UP ON
OCTOBER WHICH IS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AWARENESS MONTH AND
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS. SPEAKING OUT
ABOUT THIS ISSUE. WE CAN CAN TO
SITE A LEVEL CHANGE STRENGTH
AFTER SUPPORT FOR- ANDERSON.
THE FLOW THOSE. PART ATHLETES
THAT LEAD TO VIOLENCE SUCH AS
EARLY CHILDHOOD IN HOME
VISITATION PARENTING SKILLS AND
MARK. AND WITH ALL OF THIS THAT
I'VE SHARED BARELY SCRATCH THE
SURFACE I HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
WE HAVEN'T TALKED. MUCH ABOUT
CHILDREN SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
SO MUCH MORE AND NEED FOR EVERY
AGENCY WITH AND OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT FOCUSED ON DOMESTIC-
IS REALLY IMPERATIVE. AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL RIGHT NOW
ORDERED PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIONS WORKING ON THE
NATIONAL ACTION PLAN TO ADDRESS
GENDER BASED FINAL. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW I THINK
ABOUT HERE AND HARPER OF I
THINK THE CALIFORNIA LOCAL I.
WITH EACH AND EVERY STATE
AGENCY THAT IS TOUCHING THE
SURVIVORS THERE NEEDS. REALLY
INCORPORATING THE NEEDS. OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SO
THEREFORE. SO THERE'S CLEARLY
CHEN BUT WORKS TO BE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF THAT
WORK AS A PARTNER WITH ALL OF
YOU. I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HOSTING THIS CONVERSATION.
CHRYSOCOLLA THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR INSIGHTFUL
TESTIMONY AND WE WILL NOW GO TO
A TEAM THAT RESOLVES. WESTERN
MAKE IT AFTERNOON YES GO AHEAD
YEAH. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE I'M
AT I AM WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY I AM ONE OF
THEIR POLICY ADVOCATE. WESTERN
CENTER IS A STATE WIDE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW FIRM THAT
REPRESENTS THE INTERESTS OF LOW
INCOME AMERICANS IN NEED OF
HOUSING HEALTH CARE AND PUBLIC
BENEFITS. PRIOR TO JOINING
WESTERN CENTER I WAS EIGHT
TENANTS RIGHT TO THE BEACH AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEY AND LOCK
ANGELA RYE FRESH ALIVE IN THE
PICTURE AS WELL AS WORKING WITH
SURVIVORS ANYTHING EVICTION.
AND ONE OF THE BIG THINGS THAT
I THOUGHT WOULD BE PROVIDED IN
SECTIONS THAT THEY HAVE TO MAKE
A VERY TOUGH DECISION BETWEEN
FACING HOMELESSNESS OR ABUSE
AND OFTEN TIME BECAUSE THEY HAD
THE DECISION- THEY EITHER FELL
INTO HOMELESSNESS. OR THEY WENT
BACK TO THE YEAR. AND SO WE
KNOW THAT HOW IS. IN HOW MUCH
ARE IN. LEAN BACK WE THAT NINE
TWO PER. OF WOMEN WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS HAVE
ALSO EXPERIENCED SOME FORM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND 50% OF
WOMEN EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WE'RE EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THE MONTHS
IMMEDIATELY PRECEDING THEIR
HOMELESSNESS. AND ANOTHER THING
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT IN
THE DISCUSSION IS THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
INTERPERSONAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DID NOT IMPACT ALL SURVIVORS
THE SAME WAY THAT THOSE
SURVIVORS WORK FROM
MARGINALIZED IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES OFTEN FACE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO SERVICES
AND THAT BE LANGUAGE BARRIERS
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON THEIR
STATUS. OR OTHER TYPES OF
HOUSING BARRIERS- FOR EXAMPLE
RACIAL OR ETHNIC BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING HOUSING. FOR
IMMIGRANT WOMEN THERE IN THE
48% INCREASE IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AFTER THEY EMIGRATE TO
THE UNITED STATES BUT WE DID
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN AS A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE AND
REPORTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES FOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN REPORTS OF
ICE ARRESTING SURVIVORS REPORT
THEIR RECEIPT. AND OTHER VIBER
TO SEEK RELIEF THROUGH
PROTECTIONS SUCH AS BALLOT OR
TRIED TO ENGAGE IN AND BENEFIT
THAT THEY MAY HAVE BETTER
LEAVE. THERE'S A POWER DYNAMIC
BECAUSE THEIR ISSUES ARE HAVE
TO BE A CITIZEN OF THE UNITED
STATES SOMETIME BUT JUST TO BE.
AT THE STATE. I ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT IDEA IS THE
BILL WESTERN CENTER BECAUSE-
CALLED EIGHTY FOUR. SIXTY ONE
RIGHT THEN WE MEMBERS. WHICH
YOU MAY. PASSED JUST. AND BILL
WILL CREATE EQUITY IN UNDOCK
AND WORK. I GOT TO FORM FEDERAL
IN THE WITH THE FOR THE PRIVATE
I THINK YOU. KNOW HAPPEN
MANAGED. BURDEN OR ADMINISTER
PROCESS THE FOR THAT. TO ACT
SERVICES. THEY CAN DO SO
WITHOUT WAITING FOR ANY
ADMINISTRATIVE. DELAYS BUT I
WANT TO CENTER AT MY
CONVERSATION MAINLY ON. THAT IS
MY SPECIAL. AND REMAIN
RECOGNIZE. RATHER EIGHT DO
BETTER AND PROVIDING HOUSING
SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS. AND SO
THE FIRST ONE IN BY ENGAGING
AND- AND IMPROVING SURVIVOR
SERVICES. AND THE SURVIVOR
SERVICES THAT WERE DEFECTING
THE SECOND TO THE STATE HAVE TO
BE TRAUMA INFORMED AND THEY
HAVE TO BE SURVIVOR CENTERED
AND THEY SHOULDN'T EXCLUDE
PROVIDER RATE BASED ON
STANDING. AND THEY SHOULD ALSO
PRIVATE ACT THE THING UP BUT
THERE IS. FOR EXAMPLE AND THE
ADULT VALLEY AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THERE ARE THREE
DIFFERENT RIGHT IT. WELL ONE OF
THE REQUIREMENTS IS THAT THE
SURVIVOR GOES TO THE ACTUAL
BRICK AND MORTAR AREA. AND IN
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY IT'S A
PRETTY LARGE AREA MANY
SURVIVORS MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO A CAR IN ORDER TO GET THE
BRICK AND MORTAR AREA. AND SO
THAT PROVIDE THE BARE YEAR FOR
THEM TO ACCESS THE SERVICES.
ONE WAITED. THAT WOULD NEED TO
INVEST IN LOW BARRIER MOBILE
THIRD THING. THAT WILL NEED TO
MEET THE SURVIVOR IN AN AREA
WHERE THEY FELT UNCOMFORTABLE
THAT COULD BE LIKE A COFFEE
SHOP OR PARK OR WHEREVER THEY
FEEL MOST COMFORTABLE. SO THAT
THERE IS THAT- BUT THEY CAN
MEET THE SURVIVOR AND PROVIDE
THE SERVICES. THERE'S ALSO
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE I KNOW
LANGUAGE ACCESS OR BECAUSE THEY
ARE WORKING REMOTE IT'S YOU
ACCESS EACH TRANSLATOR. AND WE
WANT TO WORK PROGRAMS THAT USE
LANGUAGE BARRIER. AND ALTHOUGH
THING FOR THE I'M ACCESS TO
SERVICE. AND WE DO FIND IN SOME
AREAS THAT- THERE IS. NOT A
GREAT UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
LINK OF HOUSING SERVICES.
PROVIDERS AND THOSE
EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
BECAUSE THEY DO YOU FACE.
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS COMPARED
TO THOSE WHO HAVE NOT OF YET.
EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SO WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ANY
HOUSING PROVIDERS OR ANY
SERVICES THAT OFFER HOUSING
SERVICES. MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE THOMAS INFORMED AND VERY
UNIQUE TO PROVIDE FOR. AND
THAT'S AREA THAT WE WOULD TO
BOOK ON THAT LIKE THE STATE
OKAY ON IS. TRUMP THE THIRD.
DID YOU WHAT DID FOR THEM AND
FOR THE UNIQUE SITUATION AND
ONE OF THE BEST WAY THEY CAN DO
THAT BY PROVIDING UNRESTRICTED.
I'M CAPS DIRECT FUNDING TO THE
SURVIVOR THEMSELVES. NOW
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAVE
NINETEEN ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO
YOU HAVE FEDERAL FUNDING OUR
FEDERAL PRACTICAL FINDING MORE
SURVIVORS. BUT THE SURVIVOR
OFTEN HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
PROGRAM RATHER THAN THE PROGRAM
GIVING THE FUNDING DIRECTLY TO
THE PROVIDER. AND NUMBER
EXAMPLE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I SAW- WELL LITIGATING A
PARTICULAR IN THE- YOU CAN'T
THEM OFF AND TO LIVE IS THAT.
FEEDS SURVIVOR HAD IT THE
ABUSER ARRESTED AND REMOVED
FROM THE HOME. BUT THE FACT THE
RUBBER COULDN'T PAY FOR THE
RENT BECAUSE- YOU. YOU'RE
CONTROLLING ALL OF THE FINANCES
AND THE SURVIVOR DIDN'T HAVE
ECONOMIC SECURITY. FOR THE
ORGANIZATION THAT WE WORK WITH
OFFERED TO PROVIDE THE LANDLORD
WHERE. THE RENT THE LANDLORD
REFUSED TO TAKE IT IN THE
LANDMARK DID NOT WANT TO FINE.
INVADE THEIR TAX DOCUMENTS. I
KNOW WHAT WOULD BE THE OPTION
FOR THE PROVIDER. THEY CAN
EITHER CONTINUE WITH THE
ADDICTION AND ADDICTION
PROTECTION FOR SURVIVORS ARE
NOT VERY STRONG IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE- SOME OF. THE LARGE. OR
THEY CAN I HAVE A SETTLEMENT OF
AND OUT AND HOMELESSNESS
TEMPORARY SHELTERS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY MY- AND HAD TO GO
IT OPTION AND SHE- ALMOST NEXT.
BUT THIS NOT HAVE BEEN A
PROBLEM A VERY IN SHE THE
FUNDING TO GIVEN TO. BECAUSE
SHE COULD HAVE. THE RENT GOING
FORWARD AND THE- AND THERE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO BE THAT.
DOCUMENT REQUIRE NAY FROM THE
PROGRAM. AND IT'S NOT JUST THAT
PROVIDE VERY- YOU NEED SOME FOR
DATE WE HAVE TO TRUST THAT THEY
WILL USE IT FOR THEIR NEEDS
YEAH KNOW WHETHER THAT- I HAD
ONE MOM WHO HAD TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THE RENT OR PAYING. FOR
THE ON HER CAR. AND BUT THE
LAST THING THAT I DO WANT TO
FOCUS ON IS AS DEVELOPING AND
FINDING INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
THAT WORKING CONTENT INJECTION
WITH COMMUNITY TO BUILD LASTING
RELATIONSHIPS AND WORK THE
PRIVATE FACILITY. AS WE'VE
HEARD THERE IS A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PARTICULARLY
FOR SURVIVORS. AND THERE IS A
WAY THAT WE CAN TRY TO COME
BACK SOME OF THAT ONE OF BY
DEVELOPING. OUT OF. HOUSING.
AND COMMUNITIES THAT ARE. RIGHT
OKAY AND THAT DON'T WORK IN
CHEN IN THE CASE AND BROWN. BUT
THE OTHER THING THAT WE CAN DO
AND WITH OUR LOCAL LANDLORDS
ARE LOCAL PH A IS THAT OUR
LOCAL ORGANIZATION TO DEVELOP A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN. THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION AND THE
LANDLORD THAT WILL. SPECIFIC
NEEDS AFTER FIVE OR THREE
EIGHT. SOME TIMES WE ALSO HEAR
THAT SURVIVOR CAN FADE. YEAH
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON RACE OR
THEY MAKE A PROACTIVE. LANDLORD
OR THEY NEED SOME SORT OF
INTERVENTION SERVICES. AND BY
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND THE
HOUSING PROVIDERS. WE CAN TRY.
TO BUILD SOME OF THAT GAP.
LASTLY DO TO- SAY THAT THEY'RE
ALSO HAVE TO BE A **** AND THEN-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. OR
SURVIVORS FROM TEN AND
EMERGENCY SHELTER TO WIN AND A
VARIETY OF STATE STABLE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
SURVIVORS FOR A MINUTE SO WE
NEED TAKE FILLED- I'M IN A WAY
THAT. CENTER SURVIVOR VOICES
AND ALSO SHIP THEM TOWARD
HAVING ABLE AFFORDABLE
PERMANENT HOUSING. THE ONE THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU
AND THE MEMBERS FOR HOLDING
THIS IMPORTANT MEETING AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TINA RESOLVES
AND WE CLEARLY HAVE HEARD A
FROM. MESSAGE THROUGHOUT THE
TESTIMONIES TODAY HOUSING IS
TOP PRIORITY TO BE ABLE TO FIND
SAFE PLACES AND ENVIRONMENTS
FOR VICTIMS TO BE ABLE TO GO
AND BEGIN THE RECOVERY PROCESS.
AS WELL AS- JOBS AND BEING ABLE
TO DEVELOP THAT INDEPENDENT
ENVIRONMENT AWAY FROM THE
ABUSER. AND INCLUDING THE IN
THAT WOULD BE- EDUCATION AND
JOB TRAINING- AND THEN- ACCESS
ACCESS TO EFFICIENT PROGRAMS OR
SHALL I SAY AFFECT OR OFFICIAL
ACCESS TO EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS.
SO THOSE ARE ALL VERY VERY
IMPORTANT HOUSING ALSO BEING AN
ADDITIONAL PASSION OF MINE.
AND- I REALLY HAVE A I'VE I'VE
LEARNED THE SIGNIFICANCE OF NOT
JUST AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT
ACCESS TO THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE HAVE SO MANY
DIFFERENT RESOURCES THAT ARE
OUT THERE. BUT FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO KNOW ABOUT THEM FIRST
AND THEN BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE
AND BE ABLE TO REACH OUT TO
THEM IS ALSO JUST AS IMPORTANT.
I DO HAVE AND WE HAVE JUST A
COUPLE OF MINUTES LEFT- BEFORE
CLOSING I DO HAVE A QUESTION
THAT JANET SAID LEE HAD MADE
REFERENCE TO. SOMETHING THAT I
THOUGHT WAS. WE IT THERE'S ME
REAL- A REAL SHARP AND THAT
WAS- PREVENTION. AND WE'VE
ALWAYS HEARD THE PHRASE AND AN
OUNCE OF PREVENTION IS BETTER
THAN A POUND OF CURE. AND MY
QUESTION WOULD BE AND THIS IS
FOR ANY OF THE PANELISTS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK BUT- JANET
SAID LEE HAD MADE REFERENCE TO
IT. HOW CAN WE DISRUPT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL PATHWAYS TOWARD
INTERPERSONAL INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE THAT PIPELINE ENDS I
BELIEVE SEVERAL SPEAKERS AND
PANELISTS SPOKE OF IT AS A
CYCLE- BUT HOW CAN WE DISRUPT
THAT CYCLE AND HOW CAN WE-
DISRUPT THE PIPELINE. THAT
LEADS INTO- IN A PERSONAL
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. AND
I DID NOTE GEN I HAD INSIDE
SAID SHE HAD MADE REFERENCE TO
IT OR IF ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS ON
THE PANEL WANTED TO SPEAK AS
WELL. SINGLE PANELIST TWENTY
TWO I THINK GO AHEAD. RIGHT I
THINK THAT JANET IS ACTUALLY ON
MUTE AND THEN I'M HAPPY TO OF
FOLLOW UP. COMMENTS YOU. GOING
OKAY YEAH I WOULD GONNA I THAT
COULD ACTS IS AN ERC IN THE
AREA I'M GOING TURN OKAY
GRIFFIN LET HER SPEAK BUT I
WILL TELL YOU IT DOES GO VERY
TO EDUCATE EARLIER OUR- KNOW
AND ALSO WHERE I DID SPEAK
ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE FOR- BATTERS THAT THEY
NEED TO GET INTO THESE PROGRAMS
AND SO THAT THEY DON'T SHE
SHE'S VIOLENCE TO THEIR
CHILDREN AND THAT THAT IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN
TRY TO END THE CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE WHICH IS. PERVASIVE
THROUGH THIS PROBLEM AND SO- IT
DOES REQUIRE AN EARLY
INVESTMENT AND EDUCATION BUT
CHRIS I TURN TO YOU BECAUSE I
DO KNOW THAT YOU WORK IN THIS.
AREA- QUITE A BIT. JUST WE HAVE
A MORE I'M JUST A MAN LEFT. IF
YOU CAN. GIVE US A BEST ANSWER
QUICK IS A CAN. HEY A QUICK
FIRST BILL IN. CAN KIND TO. AT
LOCAL PER TO THIS WORK AND
THERE CAN AND THEY'RE IN.
INFLUENTIAL AND- IS EMBARKING
ON CHANGING CULTURE AND NORMS
AND THINGS LIKE OUR SPORTS- AND
THEY'RE DOING HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP EDUCATION AND
SCHOOLS- AND BEERS ARE
ESSENTIAL WAYS WE CAN'T ASSUME
THAT FOLKS GROW UP. KNOWING AND
SEEING WHAT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS LOOK LIKE THAT'S
SADLY NOT THE NORM AND ALL OF
OUR HOMES NOR ARE ALL PERRANCE
EQUIPPED TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT. SOME OF THE OTHER WAYS I
THINK THOSE LAKE IN HOME
VISITATION PROGRAMS FOCUS ON
TEACHING CONSENT AND BOUNDARIES
FROM YOU KNOW PRE K. LEVELS ON
OCT. PARENTING CLASSES ENGAGING
WITH COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES
THAT MAY BE AT RISK- AND AGAIN
SOME OF THOSE FUNDAMENTAL
ECONOMIC SUPPORTS THAT CREATE-
THE BROADER REDUCTION OF
STRESSORS. THAT MAY OCCUR IN
FAMILY. THANK YOU CHRISTOPHER
THAT AND- I REALLY WANT TO
THANK COMMISSIONER SAID LEE
MISS RUSSELL VICE MAYOR WILSON
AND MISS COLOGNE AND MISS WAS
ALMOST AND MISTER SANCHEZ WITH
THE AMAZING WORK. THAT YOU ALL
DO ON- ON BEHALF OF SURVIVORS
FOR INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE I
WOULD ALSO. LIKE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH PUBLIC COMMENT IF
THERE IS PUBLIC COMMENT IN
HERE. AND IF WE COULD. PLEASE-
DISTANCE UP HERE AT THE MIKE.
M. THEN WE WILL ALSO GO TO THE
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY-
CALLS COMING IN AND JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
HEAR ME YES HI I'M INDIA
JOHNSON I AM THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF YELLOW HEART COMMITTEE
AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FIRST AND FOREMOST FOR EVEN
HOLDING THIS HEARING IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT SPECIAL THAT WE'RE
HOLDING THIS AND SPEAKING AND
ADVOCATING FOR SURVIVORS. I
WANT TO KEEP THIS BRIEF AND
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT HIGHLIGHT
ALL THE ISSUES OF VIOLENCE ARE
CONNECTED HATE CRIMES AND
STRESS FROM ONLINE SCHOOLING
INCARCERATION AND MORE ALL FROM
LACK OF RESOURCES IN
EXACERBATING THE PERSONAL
VIOLENCE. PHIL SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE WHITES THE
SURVIVORS THAT SPOKE BRIEFLY
TODAY WHICH THEY ARE SURVIVORS
COULD THEY SURVIVE A MENTAL
TRAUMA SO I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
LANGUAGE CHOICE IN USING AND
WHY WE HAD BEEN SPEAK TODAY.
BUT THESE TESTIMONIES ARE ALL
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF COPING NINETEEN IS
SPACES THAT ARE NOT TYPICALLY
SEEN AS YOU KNOW FINALLY SO
WITH THIS WE NEED TO ALWAYS
REMEMBER THE MENTAL POTENTIAL
PHYSICAL IMPACT THAT THIS CAN
HAVE A CONTRIBUTED A PERSONAL
VIOLENCE. WE ALSO NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE ADDITIONAL FORMS THAT
CAMINO WALTER AND WILLIAM ALL
BRAVELY STATED AND THAT IS A
CRITICAL THAT ONE OF THE FACETS
OF VIOLENCE WILL ALWAYS
CONTRIBUTE TO ANOTHER FACET OF
VIOLENCE WHICH THEN INCREASES
HATE CRIMES LACK MOBILITY
DEPLETED RESOURCES AND MORE ALL
OF THAT IS TIED TO
COMMUNICATION TROM OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND EVERYTHING. SO WITH
THAT WE MUST MAKE SURE ALWAYS
HELPING OUT ALL ASPECTS OF
VIOLENCE INCLUDING WHAT THEY
SPOKE ON TODAY ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE YOUTH AND
STUDENTS THAT ARE HERE PRESENT
THEY ARE OUR FUTURE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH IS BEING TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT BECAUSE THE SAME THING
THE SAME ISSUES OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE WILL
ONLY CONTINUE. IF WE DON'T
LISTEN TO THEIR VOICES NOW SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AND
ALWAYS CONSIDER THE HOLISTIC
AND WHOLE PICTURE OF EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON WHEN IT COMES
TO TRAUMA INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND PLEASE NEXT SIMPLY
STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND- YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES HI MY. NAME IS I THEIR
PEERS- I. MYSELF AS IS YELLOW
HIGH COMMITTEE. I JUST WANT TO.
PERSONALLY THANK EVERY WHO
SPOKE IT WAS VERY INFORMATIVE
AND I WANTED TO THANK. INDIA
JOHNSON AND THE LR COMMITTEE
FOR PUTTING THIS ON THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON- JOHN SHOULD BAN WITH
SEIU LOCAL TEN TO ONE- HERE
FROM SACRAMENTO I APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRACE AND THE
YELLOW HEART COMMITTEE FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER TODAY-
I'M HERE. TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE- AND HOW IT
IMPACTS FAST FOOD WORKERS
ORGANIZING WITH SEIU LOCAL TEN
TO ONE. AND THE FIGHT FOR
FIFTEEN AT FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS ARE INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS PLACES TO WORK. IN
VALLEJO ALONE FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY A
SINGLE MCDONALD'S HAD THIRTY
FOUR ASSAULTS INCLUDING TWO
SEXUAL ASSAULTS. IN THERE WERE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
POTENTIALLY VIOLENT IN
INCIDENTS. IN A SINGLE STORE AT
THIRTY TWO EIGHTY NINE CINEMA
WHERE POLICE HAD TO GET
INVOLVED. WORKERS NEED TO BE
EMPOWERED TO HELP PREVENT
VIOLENCE AND MAKE THEIR STORE
SAFER FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
CUSTOMERS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIFTY SEVEN LORENA GONZALEZ.
WOULD ENABLE WORKERS TO HAVE
THAT VOICE WORKERS HAVE CALLED
FOR SECURITY OFFICERS DURING
DANGEROUS PARTS OF THE DAY.
BETTER LIGHTING TRAINING ON DE
ESCALATION AND HOW TO MANAGE
POTENTIALLY VIOLENT SITUATIONS
AND THEPHYSICAL LAYOUT CHANGES
TO MAKE THE STORE SAFER FOR
THEM. THE MAJORITY OF FAST FOOD
WORKERS ARE WOMEN AND WORKERS
OF COLOR. AT THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
I THINK YOU ALL ADD FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING PLEASE SUPPORT
WORKER EMPOWERMENT EFFORTS LIKE
AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN. AS PART OF
THE ANSWER TO DECREASE VIOLENCE
AT WORK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SABRINA
FERAL I'M GONNA TURNING IN THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AND
CURRENTLY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER. I'M
THRILLED AND THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THIS SPACE. FOR HAVING A
CONVERSATION TO RECOGNIZE
VICTIMS SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
I'VE BEEN A PROSECUTOR FOR.
TWENTY ONE YEARS NOW. AND
DURING THAT TIME I'VE OBTAINED
JUSTICE. IN THE CRIMINAL COURT
ROOM. FOR VICTIMS OF CRIME
SPECIFICALLY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ELDER PROTECTION AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AND NOW AS I SAID
AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER. I AM
DEFINITELY ABLE TO SEE HOW. A
DRAMATIC INCIDENT LIKE OF
VIOLENT CRIME. TRICKLED DOWN
THROUGHOUT THE FAMILY SO IT'S
NOT JUST THE MOTHER. THAT'S
BEING AFFECTED IT'S THE
CHILDREN AND THEY CARRY THAT
THROUGH AND YOU SEE THAT THEY
NEED THERAPY THEY NEED HELP
WITH SCHOOL AND WHEN THEIR
TEACHERS ON UNDERSTANDING WHY
THEY ARE UNABLE TO GET A LESSON
OR OR PROGRESS IT'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE LIVING WITH VIOLENCE WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT AND IT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED HERE TODAY THAT
BATTERERS ARE PART OF THE- THE
WHOLE SOLUTION AND GETTING
PREVENTIVE HEALTH FOR THEM. AND
ONGOING HELP FOR THEM BECAUSE A
LOT OF OUR FAMILIES THEY DON'T
WANT TO SEPARATE FROM THE
BATTER SO WE HAVE TO BE
REALISTIC AND HOW DO WE HELP
THE ENTIRE FAMILY BUT OF COURSE
PUTTING WOMEN AND CHILDREN
FIRST AND CREATING A SAFE SPACE
FOR THEM SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. EMCEEING THE WITH
THE PUBLIC- COMMENT. DO WE HAVE
ANY- PUBLIC COMMENT THAT HAS
COME IN OVER THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR. AT HI MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND IT LOOKS LIKE. WE
HAVE ONE ONE IN PERSON LEFT.
PLEASE HI MY NAME IS ALLEY I AM
A SENIOR AT COLLEGE PARK HIGH
SCHOOL CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- I'M
A SURVIVOR OF TRAUMA AND I
EXPERIENCED FIRSTHAND THE
MISHANDLING OF LAWN- OF
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND I BELIEVE
THERE SHOULD BE SO MUCH MORE
REFORM AND HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
TREATS ESPECIALLY SUICIDAL
PEOPLE. AND THOSE LIKE CRISIS
CALLS- I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE SO MUCH MORE
FORM AND BE LIKE MENTAL
HOSPITAL- HOSPITALIZATION OF
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA I KNOW THERE IS A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD. FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE MENTALLY ILL.
BUT I FEEL LIKE THAT THAT IS
NOT ENOUGH FOR SOMEONE TO LIKE.
TO HEAL FROM WHAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED AND RECEIVE WHAT
THEY NEED- I THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A LOT MORE. THOUGHT
INTO HOW PEOPLE ARE TREATED
ESPECIALLY THOSE VULNERABLE
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
OPERATE THE SAME AS SOMEONE WHO
IS LIKE DEEMED NORMAL- YEAH I
THINK THAT ESPECIALLY WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN OR EVEN UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE THE
BRAIN DOESN'T STOP DEVELOPING
UNTIL TWENTY FIVE. THERE SHOULD
BE MORE- AND SO THERE SHOULD BE
MORE TRAINING BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COUNSELORS AND
THERAPISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS ON HOW TO
TREAT THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE WHAT
I'VE SEEN I PERSONALLY LIKE IT
HELPED ME A LOT TO GO THERE BUT
I SAW KIDS REALLY STRUGGLING
THAT'S ALL PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
BECAUSE OF HOW POORLY THEY WERE
TREATED. AND THESE CHILDREN ARE
USE YOUNG IS SEVEN YEARS OLD
THEY ARE VERY MUCH STRUGGLING
AND THEY- EVEN LIKE THEY CAN'T
EVEN GO BACK HOME BECAUSE OF
HOW TERRIBLE THEIR HOME LIFE IS
AND I FEEL LIKE AS LIKE A STATE
I KNOW YOU'RE PUT CALIFORNIA'S
ONE OF THE BEST SUITS TO BE AN-
BUT WE CAN DO BETTER. AND THE
IMPACT THE- WE AS A STATE HAVE
ON THESE LIKE YOUNG CHILDREN
CAN SHAPE THEM FOREVER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING ME OUT
AND I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS ARE
TRYING YOUR BEST TO CHANGE
EVERYTHING. BUT THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE WORK WE NEED TO DO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TIME AND TESTIMONY I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THINK THAT YOUR HEART
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION. ON THIS HEARING
AND- I WANT TO GIVE- PROPS TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER FOR
JOINING US TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OF FOR HIS QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND PARTICIPATION IN
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING I WOULD
ALSO LIKE T. INVITE MEMBERS TO
GIVE ANY- INPUT THAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE OTHER MEMBERS- AS THE VIEW
THIS- HEARING AND- LET'S
COLLABORATE TOGETHER AND LET'S
MOVE SOME WITH A STRONG POLICY
AND GREAT IDEAS FORWARD. AND
ALSO TO INVITE ALL THE
PANELISTS- THAT SPOKE TODAY
PLEASE FORWARD YOUR IDEAS OF
HOW THE LEGISLATURE. COULD TAKE
ACTION AND PROVIDE BETTER
SUPPORT AND- AND TO MAKE
SUPPORT AVAILABLE AND WITH MORE
EFFICIENT ACCESS- WITH THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
DEMANDS REFLECTION AND
CONTINUED DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
OUR CURRENT LAWS AND SERVICES
WORK. TO ASSIST SURVIVORS OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE I DO
WAT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR INPUT TODAY AND FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON SOLUTIONS
TO THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED HERE TODAY. THEY'RE VERY
IMPORTANT YOUR VOICE IS NEEDED
TO BE HEARD I'M GLAD IT WAS
HEARD AT LEAST FROM THIS
COMMITTEE NOW WE'RE READY TO
TAKE ACTION THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT YOUR
PARTICIPATION. AND THIS
COMMITTEE IS KNOWLEDGE.